Ja, herzlich willkommen zur Alternativlos Folge Nr. 41. Wir dachten uns, wir machen noch mal so eine kleine Jahresabschlussfolge für das Jahr 2017, jetzt wo das Jahr fast geschafft ist.
So können wir euch nicht gehen lassen, haben wir uns gedacht.
Genau. Und ja, zumal wir dieses Jahr auf dem Kongress keine FN News schon machen.
Aber warum eigentlich nicht?
Es gibt, glaube ich, so drei Gründe. Also der eine ist, es ist halt einfach irgendwie immer echt ein Sack voll Arbeit und letzten Endes war dieses Jahr so eins mit diesem ganzen Tramp-Wahnsinn, wo dann auch irgendwie Lacher rauszukitzeln, die nicht sofort im Hals stecken bleiben und irgendwie die nicht sowieso schon total offensichtlich sind.
Ich habe ja so einen Screenshot gemacht und der liegt auf meinem Desktop rum, von diesem Co-Fefe-Tweet und das war so der Moment, wo ich dachte, vergiss es. Ja, was willst du da noch? Ja, also wir können jetzt irgendwie, ich habe ja mal im Blog beschrieben, wie viel Arbeit es ist, weil man hat ja wenig Vorstellungen, da gehen also wirklich Monate an Lebenszeit rein. Nur sortieren von den ganzen Sachen. Und also wir hätten jetzt entweder sagen können, okay, wir sortieren den Trump aus, weil da hat keiner mehr Bock drauf. Das hätten wir machen können.
Aber wäre es halt auch ein echt unrepräsentatives Jahr geworden.
Ja, und es ist vor allem, gab es einfach so viel negative Scheiße dieses Jahr, dass eine Show, die das alles nochmal auf den Tisch legt, einfach noch mehr schlechte Laune macht. Also man hätte sozusagen Trump filtern müssen und die ganzen schlechten Nachrichten und da bleibt auch mal nichts übrig. Das ist so, ich hab so zwei, ich hab das vorhin hier beim Reinkommen gesagt, ich hab so zwei Lektionen aus dem Jahr. Die erste ist warten, dass es besser wird, funktioniert nicht. Das wird nicht von selber besser. Wir müssen es besser machen. Und was mir persönlich sehr gefehlt hat in diesem Jahr, sind so niveauvolle Unterhaltung. Also höheres Niveau als du, Aris. Ich hatte so ein paar Beispiele dieses Jahr. Das war irgendwie, wie war denn jetzt so Subject-Nazi-Versteher oder so. Einfach der Tonfall, in dem Leute aufeinander zugehen. Also gar nicht so, das eskaliert nicht dahin, sondern es geht schon so los, ist schon derartig vergiftet, dass ich einfach auch bei diversen Gelegenheiten dann überhaupt keinen Bock habe, irgendwie ein Gespräch anzufangen, wenn ich mir denke so, ach, weißt du. Und da müssen wir aber raus, weil das ist wirklich da, das ist mehr als Lebenszeit, die verloren geht. Ich sag immer, so bei Bitcoin kann man das gut illustrieren. Da war immer, man ärgert sich, nicht eingestiegen zu sein, aber man ärgert sich noch mehr, wenn man eingestiegen ist und dann einen Burger gekauft hat davon. In der Sekunde, wo du eine aktive Handlung begehst, ist einfach der Rückblicken, der Ärger größer. Und so ist es auch mit Gesprächen, finde ich. Ich bin jetzt, ich habe jetzt so genug Gelegenheiten einfach nicht mitgenommen dieses Jahr, weil ich dachte, das wird ähnlich, dass ich anfange, das richtig als auch einen Verlust zu empfinden. Wir müssen mehr Sendungen machen, würde ich sagen.
Ja, wir machen.
Wir müssen mehr Sendungen machen. Wir müssen einfach aufhören mit diesem Scheiß, irgendwie Geld verdienen und wir müssen einfach jetzt mal auf uns das Wichtige uns konzentrieren und je Sendungen machen. Diese Scheißerwerbsarbeit, das führt doch zu nichts.
Ja, eh nicht Arbeit und so.
Ja, ach, es gab da so ein paar Probleme dieses Jahr nicht mit der Arbeit, sondern wir haben ja eigentlich haben wir ja Fletter gehabt als Spendenmodell. Und dann ist Fletter von diesen diesen Adblock plus Leuten gekauft worden. Und dann haben wir uns gesagt, okay, wir probieren mal Patreon. Und dann kommt Patreon und hat irgendwie ein Gebührenmodell angekündigt. Du hast vorhin die Zahl gehabt, wie war das von so einer 1-Euro-Spende?
Würden dann 30 Prozent an Gebühren weggegangen sein.
Also das haben sie jetzt wieder zurückgerollt, aber so.
Also wir haben gerade mal geguckt, so irgendwie so Patreon fallen so 15 Prozent ungefähr an allen möglichen Gebühren an und.
Also wir sehen das Problem und wir diskutieren gerade, wie wir das irgendwie mal geschickt lösen. Wir fühlen eure Schmerzen.
Ja, und wir werden also wir werden im Laufe der Sendung werden wir dazu noch mal was sagen. Ja, so eine Idee.
Aber das mit dem, das mit dem irgendwie in in Graben zurückgucken wegen verpassten Gelegenheiten ist bei Bitcoin natürlich besonders krass, weil wir also eigentlich, also wir sind jetzt vielleicht nicht unbedingt die Early Adopter, die irgendwie die Sachen haben, bevor sie die anderen haben, aber Bitcoin haben wir schon echt früh gesehen. So bevor das irgendwie in Zeitungen stand natürlich. Ja und Frank hat auch ein bisschen damit rumgespielt und kam irgendwann zu mir und meinte, hey, lass uns doch mal Bitcoin spenden annehmen. Und ich hab gesagt, das ist ein Schneeballsystem, das ist alles Betrüger, das ist darauf ausgelegt, Leuten irgendwie ein Dopamin-Hit zu geben, das ist wie Casino, da will ich nicht mitmachen, weil das irgendwelchen armen Schluckern die Kohle aus der Tasche zieht. Und so Zocker will ich nicht noch. Also ich hab einen Sack voll moralisch hochwertiger Gründe gehabt, warum ich das nicht wollte. Und dann hat Frank angefangen, mir so vorzurechnen, immer so im vier Wochen Abstand, so wie deutlich wir jetzt nicht mehr arbeiten müssten, wenn wir damals Bitcoin spenden angenommen hätten. Und dann denk ich mir das schon, ah, das ist das Problem mit Anstand und Moral. Es ist halt nicht kostenlos, sondern da gibt's da halt Gelegenheiten weg. Aber ich bin ehrlich gesagt ganz zufrieden, dass ich nie irgendwie Bitcoin genommen habe und mir dann irgendwie eine Pizza geholt hab oder so. Weil das war ja mal so, das war so einer der Momente, wo alle dachten, Bitcoin könnte doch was werden. Also die ersten so Hipster irgendwie Pizza-Lieferservices angefangen haben, Bitcoin anzunehmen. Weil ursprünglich sah Bitcoin ja aus wie so ein Bezahlsystem für Alltag. Und das ist ja überhaupt nicht, wo sich das hin entwickelt hat. Das ist ja jetzt eher so eine Art Investment, ich sag mal Zocker-Geschichte. Da legst du Geld an, um mehr Geld rauszukriegen, nicht um damit was zu bezahlen.
Also ich hab ja damals auch irgendwie zwei Burger und zwei Bier für anderthalb Bitcoin gekauft. Immerhin weiß ich, dass das Geld bei jemand sehr Nettes gelandet ist, der die Laden betreibt und umgerechnet ein Kleinwagen. Wo es halt also jetzt sicherlich nicht so ist, dass irgendwie es in den falschen Händen landet. Aber ja, umgerechnet ein Kleinwagen. Es waren relativ teure Burger, aber gut, so ist es halt. Aber letzten Endes ist es halt so, dass dieses Cryptocurrency-Ding, ich denke, was so das nächste Jahr passieren wird, ist, dass sich das entscheidet, wohin die Reise da geht. Und es gibt ja da so sehr, sehr unterschiedliche Ansichten. Und ich bin da auch nicht wirklich irgendwie einer festen Meinung, weil letzten Endes ist, bei allen Währungen ist ja immer so, dass das passiert, woran die Menschen glauben. Also ist ja bei Bitcoin jetzt nicht groß anders. Natürlich gibt es halt diese Mechanismen dahinter mit dem Mining und so weiter und so fort. Und der Mathematik, die halt dafür sorgt, dass es halt nicht nur der reine Glaube und die Entscheidung von ein paar Zentralbankern ist, in welche Richtung sich eine Währung entwickelt.
Vielleicht sollten wir das auch mal erklären. Ich habe neulich so ein Gespräch gehabt, da ist mir auch klar geworden, so viele Leute hören irgendwie Bitcoin und Blockchain. Und das ist ja inzwischen ist das ja eins von diesen hohlen Marketing-Phrasen.
Ich finde dauerterte Blockchain.
Diese, genau, Blockchain in the Cloud mit irgendwie. Also das sagt man heute zum Produkt dazu, um es cooler zu machen. Blockchain, wir machen auch Blockchain. Und das muss man trennen, Bitcoin und Blockchain. Oder überhaupt die Kryptowährungen und Blockchain. Blockchain ist nämlich eigentlich eine hoch interessante Geschichte. Nämlich die Lösung für ein Problem, was lange Zeit als unlösbar galt. Nämlich die Frage, wie du aus einem völlig verteilten System, ohne Notar in der Mitte, dem alle vertrauen müssen, wie du daraus ein konsistentes Weltbild schaffst, dass die sich auf einen Zustand einigen können und der ist jetzt wahr. Das ist ein Problem, was bei Datenbanken schon immer eine Rolle spielt. Und da wird es immer so gelöst. Oder immerhin, immerhin ist jetzt zu viel. Aber da löst man es häufig so, dass die Datenbanken irgendeine Art Wahlverfahren haben und sich darauf einigen, wer jetzt zuständig ist. Aber es gibt immer noch einen, der das letzte Wort hat. Und das gibt es bei der Blockchain eben nicht. Sondern das ist ein relativ schlaues Verfahren, um einen Konsens zu finden zwischen verschiedenen Leuten, die sich gegenseitig nicht trauen müssen dafür. Und so genial das ist, so erkauft es sich das eben mit so einem Pferdefuß. Und der Pferdefuß ist, dass das Proof of Work basiert ist. Das heißt, man muss Leistung erbringen. Man muss beweisen, dass man Leistung erbracht hat, um Recht zu bekommen im System. Das ist sozusagen, es bildet die eine Art von Geld ab auf eine andere Art von Leistung. Und die verbraucht eben Strom. Das heißt, es ist kein intellektuelles Spiel, sondern dem stehen tatsächliche Realweltkosten gegenüber. Und das hat dazu geführt, dass wir jetzt ganz interessante Effekte haben, von denen Frank gleich mal ein paar Anekdoten erzählen wollte, wie das in der Praxis abläuft. Aber Bitcoin-Mining ist vergleichsweise teuer geworden. Nicht nur, weil man das gar nicht mehr mit Standard-Hardware macht, sondern mit irgendwelchen Asics. Erklär doch mal den Weg dahin. Der war nämlich auch ganz lustig.
Am Anfang war es so, dass die...
Der erste Client war irgendwie so ein Programm, das du halt runtergeladen hast und er hat das auf deiner CPU gemacht.
Genau, er hat das einfach auf der normalen CPU gemacht. Dann wurde relativ schnell klar, dass diese Operationen sich mit Grafikkartenprozessoren so viel schneller ausführen lassen. Der nächste Schritt waren halt Grafikkarten, auf denen dann halt diese Programme liefen. Dann haben sich die Leute, wie jetzt dann halt neulich auch bei Ethereum, wo die durch dieselbe Phase gelaufen ist, noch so eine andere Kryptowährung, haben sich die Leute halt so Grafikkarten gekauft und haben dann ihre PCs damit vollgestopft und dann halt irgendwie Mining gemacht. Und wenn man zur damaligen Zeit also als Mining noch mit Grafikkarten ging und es so noch so halbwegs profitabel war, weil man da rechtzeitig eingestiegen ist, dann fielen da durchaus halt schon mal so ein paar Bitcoin am Tag raus, so ganz früh. Also es war halt durchaus, wenn man halt so ein etwas größeres Setup hatte. Und das wird dann halt graduell weniger, weil Bitcoin und alle anderen wesentlichen Kryptowährungen haben halt diese Steigerungen drin, dass es also immer schwieriger wird, diese Berechnungen durchzuführen, was halt da so eingebaute Deflation quasi ist.
Man sollte vielleicht dazu sagen, Bitcoin klingt wie eine Währung, aber Blockchain ist eigentlich keine Währung, sondern ein Ledger-System, eine Buchhaltung.
Das ist halt eigentlich nichts weiter als...
Der Währungsteil ist virtuell obendrauf.
Genau. Also was die Blockchain eigentlich de facto tut, ist halt ein verteiltes Notariat. Also alles, was es tut, ist zu sagen, hier ist eine Transaktion, diese Transaktion geben, also was weiß ich, ich gebe jetzt Fefe ein Euro und ihr alle habt gesehen, dass ich oder gehört, dass ich Fefe ein Euro gegeben habe und ihr könnt es bezeugen.
Und ich kann später nicht sagen, was für ein Euro habe ich nie gekriegt.
Beziehungsweise ich kann nicht sagen, ich habe Fefe nie ein Euro gegeben und den nochmal ausgeben. Weil das ja genau das Problem bei bei elektronischen Währungen ist ja also eines der Kernprobleme, das ist halt dieses Double Spending. Das ist also, dass man halt eine Transaktion, also einen Wert nochmal ausgibt. Und dieses öffentliche Notariat besteht also im Wesentlichen darin, dass alle, die halt Mining machen, betreiben halt so Stempelmaschinen, die halt einfach die ganze Zeit halt Transaktion stempeln, habe ich gesehen, habe ich gesehen, habe ich gesehen, habe ich gesehen. Und in dieses System eingebaut ist aber auch die Schöpfung neuer neuen Geldes, also sozusagen man macht, betreibt dieses Mining, damit attestiert man die ganze Zeit Transaktionen. Das sind dann diese Confirms, die man da so in Bitcoin Clients oder auch in anderen Coin Clients sieht. Und diese, dieses Confirm einer Transaktion ist gleichzeitig quasi ein Lottoschein dafür, dass man sozusagen neues Geld kriegt. Also so kann man es vereinfacht sagen. Und deswegen betreiben die Miners zum einen halt, um diese Mining-Fee einzunehmen. Das heißt also für diese Transaktionen nehmen die halt irgendwie so ein paar hundertstel oder tausendstel Bitcoin. Und die, manchmal haben sie halt Glück und dann ist halt in dem Block, der da gemeint wird, dann halt noch ein ganzer Bitcoin drin, der halt irgendwie dann neues Geld ist. Und dann können sie den halt auch ausgeben. Das sind also die beiden Business-Modelle für diese Miners. Das heißt also, die Menge an Transaktionen, die abgewickelt werden kann in so einer Blockchain, Währungen hängen davon ab, wie viele Leute diese Währung meinen. Und dann gibt es da so alle an Mechanismen, dass also die Gebühren sich automatisch skalieren und so, dass halt irgendwie es immer einen Incentive dafür gibt, für die Miner halt irgendwie genug Meineinkapazität in der Währung vorzuhalten. Also das ist ein relativ komplexes System, was da entsteht. Aber im Wesentlichen beruht es halt darauf, dass alle daran glauben, dass es eine coole Sache ist. Und dass es halt irgendwie technisch so aufgebaut ist, dass es halt irgendwie jetzt nicht ohne Weiteres gegamet werden kann. Da gibt es natürlich immer wieder Ausreißer, so also was wie Ethereum, die dann halt festgestellt haben, so ups, wir haben uns da so ein bisschen verrannt. Und was dann passiert ist im Sinne der Hardfork, denn also die die Währungen halt irgendwie sich da vertan haben. Oder sie zum Beispiel feststellen, dass die Blockgröße für die Anzahl der Transaktionen, die halt in einem Block zusammengefasst werden, der dann halt gestempelt wird, dass die zu klein ist, dann machen sie diese Block-Size größer. Und dazu müssen sie dann Sachen ändern. Und das nennt man dann so einen Hardfork. Und an dieser Stelle sagen halt die meiner, die daran mitmachen bei diesem Fork, okay, wir akzeptieren jetzt diese Änderung dieses Verfahrens, des Protokolls und berechnen ab jetzt anders ausgehend, also ab einem bestimmten Block in dieser Kette voneinander verketteter Transaktionen, die dann immer abgestempelt werden. Und dann geht es halt irgendwie in eine oder andere Richtung weiter. Und so ist halt so diese, die Lingo dieser Welt ist halt eine relativ unterhaltsame Absode. So und die kann auf den ersten Blick auch sehr verwirrend sein. Am Ende ist es halt so die Frage, ob es halt irgendwie, ja sozusagen die Spekulation ist, die sich da jetzt gerade in den Kursen dieser Kryptowährungen, niederschlägt. Es gibt eine Gegentheorie und die lautet, dass nur die reale Inflation des Fiat Money darin sichtbar wird.
Ja klar. Das Fiat Money ist ja sozusagen der Feind von den Kryptoleuten, die alle glauben, die Illuminati kontrollieren den Money Supply. Und das ist auch nicht völlig von der Hand zu beginn.
Wenn du dir so anguckst, was so irgendwie so die Zentralbank da so drucken und in welchen Mengen und was die damit tun, dann kann man schon...
Die Effekte davon sind ja auch spürbar. Wir haben jetzt hier gerade wieder so eine Milliardenübernahme gehabt. Disney kauft, wer war das? Wen kauft Disney gerade irgendwie? Schön vergessen. Aber jedenfalls so, dann werden wir eben 60 Milliarden bezahlt. Und das liegt daran, dass Geld im Moment günstig zu haben, dass Kredite sind günstig zu haben. Und das liegt daran, dass die Notenbanken die Zinsrate niedrig gesetzt haben. Als Reaktion auf die Weltwirtschaftskrise. Das heißt, es stimmt schon, dass Fiat Money Nachteile hat, die man tatsächlich sehen kann. Diese ganzen Monster irgendwie Konzern A kauft, Konzern B. Das ist eine direkte Folge daraus.
Und ich meine, wenn du dir anguckst, was die mit dem gedruckten Geld gerade machen, dass sie halt negativ Zinsen an Zentralbanken nehmen müssen und so.
Aber gedruckt ist schon der falsche Ausdruck an der Stelle.
Also generiert, ja. Dann kann man schon sagen, dass irgendwie eine Blockchain-Währung, bei der man wenigstens noch irgendwie Energie verbrennen und den Planeten ein bisschen vernichten muss, hat zumindest noch mehr Reden.
Macht weniger kaputt. Das finde ich krass. Wenn du sagst, den Planeten aktiv kaputt machen durch Energieinvestitionen in eine völlig virtuelle Währung, macht weniger kaputt, als die Illuminaten mit ihrem Geld zu pleichen.
Ich hab nicht gesagt, dass sie weniger kaputt machen. Was ich gesagt habe, ist nur, oder was ich sagen wollte, dass es eine solidere Grundlage für eine Währung ist.
Also wir sollten vielleicht erklären, so Informatik, das ist alles sehr schwer zu erklären, die Grundlagen. Aber so als Bild kann man sich vielleicht vorstellen, dass man eine Zielscheibe aufstellt und jeder kriegt einen Bogen und hat die Augen verbunden und muss jetzt versuchen, Pfeile in alle Himmelsrichtungen zu schießen und versuchen, dieses Ziel zu treffen. Und die Größe von dem Ziel wird angepasst, wird immer kleiner. So je effizienter man die Möglichkeiten findet, die Leute fangen dann irgendwie an parallel zu schießen, um ihre Zielwahrscheinlichkeit zu erhöhen. Aber der technische Fortschritt hilft zwar, mehr Pfeile parallel abzuschießen, aber darauf reagiert eben die Kryptowährung, indem sie das Ziel kleiner schaltet. Das heißt, es gibt einige so Regelkreisläufe. Anderer Regelkreisläufe ist, dass die Gebühren, die so ein Minor erhebt für eine Transaktion, die bestimmt nicht der Minor, sondern die sind eine externe Regel.
Die kann es aber auch mehr bieten übrigens, ne? Also dann haben wir eine höhere Geschwindigkeit.
Ja, gut, das ist halt Zocker, Zockerscheiße, ne? Aber gut, der Punkt, den ich machen wollte, ist, dass die Gebühren, die Mindestgebühren, hängen halt davon ab, wie viel Transaktionen gerade ausstehen und noch beglaubigt werden müssen. Das heißt, das ist an der Stelle auch ein selbstregulierendes System. Und das Ausmaß, in dem dieses System selbst erhaltend, selbst regulierend gebaut wurde, ist schon atemberaubend, möchte ich mal so sagen. Denn es ist im Herzen eigentlich so ein Schneeballsystem, was darauf basiert, dass alle dran glauben, dass es jemand anderes gibt, der ihnen ihre virtuellen Internetpunkte wieder abkaufen wird. Und es gibt aber Dutzende von Regelkreisen laufen, die dafür sorgen, dass es tatsächlich Anreize gibt, dass das System weiterlaufen wird. Und das ist schon, also es ist jetzt unfair, wenn ich sage, die kriminelle Energie, die reingeflossen ist, um dieses System zu erfinden, das ist kreative Energie. Genau, kreative Energie, das ist der richtige Ausdruck. Also es ist schon umhauend, finde ich, dass diese Erfindung gelungen ist von Blockchain und Bitcoin.
Na die ist ja, blickt ja auf eine relativ lange Tradition zurück von vorherigen...
Na von Leuten, die es versucht haben, aber der erste, der es wirklich geschafft hat.
Also wenn man so zurückguckt, kommt es ja, also steht es ja in so einer Tradition von halt so den Cypherpunk-Krypto-Anarchisten, die ja schon in den 90ern so Visionen von so ähnlichen Sachen hatten. Also halt so quasi eine, teilweise auch aus einer sehr libertären, irgendwie Staat-raushalten-Perspektive.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, eher libertär als anarchistisch ist so mein Eindruck gewesen.
Na es gibt da so verschiedene Schulen und Strömungen so in diesem Bereich. Es ist halt auch ein...
Vielleicht erklären wir erst mal den Unterschied, oder? Weil viele Leute kennen das gar nicht.
Na die Libertären sind halt Leute, die halt sagen, irgendwie so der Markt wird halt schon regeln. So wie es aus der Tradition von Ayn Rand kommt.
Nur der Markt darf es regeln.
Genau, nur der Markt darf es regeln.
Der Staat hat sich gefälligst rauszuhalten. Und zwar weitgehender als man so glaubt, wenn man noch nie mit so einem Libertären geredet hat. Ich hab da mal so ein Gespräch geführt mit einem, der meinte, so wenn du die Kohle hast, dir eine Atombombe zu kaufen, dann sollte der Staat dir nicht im Weg stehen. Weil du hast die Kohle, du hast dein Recht.
Genau.
Es geht ziemlich weit, was dir interessiert, natürlich ein einzelner Teil. Aber es ist durchaus eine Sache, die...
Das ist ein sehr konsequentes Argument.
Ja, also ich weiß nicht, ob das mehr als fähig ist unter den Libertären, aber so Geschichten, wie die Kommune kauft sich ihre eigene Polizei, oder das wird privatisiert, das finde ich völlig normal. Alles, was nicht privatisiert ist, ist aus Sicht eines Libertären ein unerlaubter Markteingriff und marktverzerrend. Das heißt, das klingt jetzt alles sehr weit weg, aber auch die Gründungsgrundlagen der EU sind vor allem auf den freien Markt ausgerichtet. Also so weit weg ist das nicht. Die sind nur konsequenter in der Auslegung. Und Anarchisten sind auch Leute, die keinen Staat haben wollen, aber nicht aus anderen Gründen, nicht weil sie persönliche Bereicherung gut finden. Viele, viele Libertäre sind so Leute, die sich dann ein Haus auf dem Hügel bauen und Schusswaffen im Keller haben. Also die Überlappung zwischen Libertären und Schusswaffeneigentümern ist erschütternd hoch in den USA. Und Anarchisten sind eher so, ich will nicht sagen Idealisten, aber Leute, die glauben, wenn man den gesamten Staat und seine Kontrollinstrumente wegmachen würde, dann würden sich halt lokale Gruppen bilden, die das dann schon hinkriegen.
Genau, da gibt es halt auch wieder eine Vielzahl von Schulen, aber die Kryptoanarchisten und die Anarchosyndikalisten, die also sagen, okay, die am besten funktionieren, menschliche Strukturen, durch freiwilligen Zusammenschluss von Menschen, die für sich sich ein Werk von Regeln geben und sich dann daran halten, da gibt es halt schon große Überlappungen. Und aus dieser gesandten ideologischen Blase entstanden halt dann auch die Movements wie die Cypher-Punks, die dann sagen, okay, wir haben jetzt Technologie, wir haben Krypto, wir haben Netze, wir könnten jetzt halt ein System bauen oder Systeme bauen, die halt diese Vision möglich machen. Also nicht im Sinne von den Startstürzen, sondern im Sinne von parallele Strukturen, die halt nicht unbedingt vom Start abhängig sind.
Ich würde aber vor Krypto-Währungen anfangen, denn die...
Also das erste davon war Modulation. Das war das erste System, was in diese Richtung ging. Da gab es den Mojo als Währung drin. Und das war ein System, wo man sagen konnte, man kann halt Services im Internet anbieten oder auch alle Bücher in anderen Services anbieten, für die es dann halt ein Micropayment-System gibt, was halt irgendwie auf anonyme bzw. anonymisierte Kommunikation mit Mixnetworks dran getackert und so funktioniert hat. Die waren ein bisschen zu früh dran. Das war halt, ich glaube, 2002 oder so.
Ja, aber es geht ja noch frühere. Also die Leute, die PGP in Buchform exportiert haben, das waren auch Kryptoanarchisten. Es geht nicht nur, die Währung ist ein Teil, von dem lange Zeit nicht klar war, ob das überhaupt gelingen kann, so eine digitale Währung zu haben. Da haben Leute dran gearbeitet. Einer der ersten, die wirklich vielversprechende Ansätze hat, war David Schohm, den wir damals auch verfolgt haben, weil das sehr spannend aussah. Ist aber nichts geworden, weil der irgendwie versucht hat, das kommerziell zu machen und das hat sich nicht getragen. Das war so ein Visionär, der war auch seinerzeit voraus.
Der war deutlich seinerzeit voraus.
Aber also immer zu illustrieren, was für ein Gedankengut in diesem libertären Bereich ist. Es gibt da einen Essay aus dem Jahre 1996 oder so. Assassination Politics, das finde ich ganz illustrativ. Das sollten wir mal erwähnt haben.
Tabell, ja.
Und zwar war sozusagen der, also es ist nicht klar, ob das ernst gemeint ist oder nicht. Wenn man das liest, denkt man, das ist ja eine tolle Satire. Aber wenn man den Typ trifft.
Genau, ich habe den Typen tatsächlich neulich irgendwie auf einer Konferenz gesehen. Und der meint das tatsächlich ernst. Also es ist nicht schon politisch, dir das zu sagen. Wenn man halt eine anonyme Währung hat und ein anonymes Kommunikationssystem, dann kann man ja wetten auf irgendwie das Ableben von Politikern zum Beispiel abschließen.
Wenn du nicht zufrieden bist mit der Arbeit, die der macht, dann kannst du ja fünf Dollar setzen.
Genau, und wenn sich genügend Leute finden, die diese Wette irgendwie eingehen, dann wird sich schon jemand finden, der ihren Inhalt in die Tat umsetzt.
Also Wette ist jetzt vielleicht ein euphemistischer... Also es geht im Wesentlichen darum, dass man so einen Pool aufbaut, wenn du unzufrieden bist für das Umdieten von einem Politiker und wenn empfindet sich schon jemand. Und das Ganze basiert halt auf der Idee, dass die Kommunikation natürlich irgendwie per Kryptographie gesichert ist, dass nicht...
Und anonymisiert wird.
Und genau, also dass das keiner sehen kann, wer in den Pool eingezahlt hat. Aber so die Idee, dass du quasi Amtsinhaber weg ermorden lassen kannst mit einem anonymen Beitrag, so eine Art Crowdfunding für Ermordung. Und das war also relativ früh, noch vor diesem ganzen Kryptowährungskram. Aber es ist eigentlich genauso die Ecke. Und das ist auch eine Sache, an der Tor heute noch knappst, finde ich, dass die auch im Grunde ungern darüber reden wollen, aus welcher Ecke eigentlich die ganzen Kryptoideale kommen. Weil das waren nicht unbedingt so gut Menschen, die an die an die armen verfolgten chinesischen Dissidenten gedacht haben, sondern die fanden in erster Linie der Staat hat gefälligst, sich daraus rauszuhalten, was ich hier mache. Und wenn es anderen hilft, gut.
Das ist auch der Grund, warum Tor ja diesen im Wesentlichen halt seine Anti-Censorship-Sachen in den Vordergrund stellt und halt die Sachen...
Klar, weil das eine viel schöneres Story ist.
Die De-Animisierungen sind halt natürlich... Naja, also das Problem dabei ist halt am Ende, dass die... Also, Association Politics ist halt natürlich irgendwie ein bescheuertes Konzept. Also ich war neulich von der Konferenz und der erzählte da seine 2.0-Version davon und irgendwie...
Oh, es gibt eine 2.0-Version?
Ja, fuck, ist das jetzt... Und der glaubt da tatsächlich dran und irgendwie die... Also wirklich sehr... Und dann irgendwann kam dann so ein Publikumsanmerk, der meinte, hey Jim, aren't you old enough to know that killing people wouldn't change the system? Und damit war ich sozusagen, da war natürlich dann okay, im Wesentlichen ist es vorbei, so ja. Und ja, das ist halt genau das Problem, der Punkt, dass halt also tatsächlich die Idee, dass man irgendwie durch Umbring an so einer Person halt irgendwie politische Veränderungen erzielen könnte, ist halt einfach bescheuert. Naja.
Aber der Punkt ist, wir haben jetzt alle Bausteine zusammen mit Bitcoin. Das war so der letzte Baustein, der gefehlt hat.
Nee, Bitcoin war nicht der Baustein. Bitcoin ist ja traceable. Das heißt also tatsächlich ist die Nachverfolgbarkeit von Bitcoin-Transaktionen ist halt ehemalig gut, dass also bisher sich niemand getreut hat, darauf Assistenation-Politik zu bauen.
Naja, Moment.
Aber es gibt halt noch andere Krypto-Balladen.
Also traceable heißt ja nicht, dass dein Name dransteht, ne?
Nee, aber...
Theoretisch kannst du irgendwie eine Milliarde Wallets aufmachen?
Also es gibt halt zum Beispiel aber, so bei Bitcoin gibt es halt irgendwie dieses Problem, es sind Taintings. Das heißt also, du hast halt Bitcoins, die du eigentlich nicht mehr ausgeben kannst, weil die zum Beispiel aus einem Diebstahl bei einer Exchange stammen. Oder weil die an eine bestimmte Organisation gegangen sind. Und die halt dann...
Genau, also Bitcoin basiert eben auf Blockchain und das ist ein Buchhaltungssystem. Das heißt, die gesamte Historie von allen Transaktionen ever im System liegt vor und muss auch vorliegen. Das ist Teil des Konzepts. Und das sind inzwischen, ich glaube, ein paar Terabyte, 80 Terabyte oder so. Wie viel war das? Hast du das noch im Kopf?
Weiß ich nicht mehr.
Aber es sind echt viel Daten und die müssen halt alle Mining-Teilnehmer mit sich rumschleppen.
Das ist so... Die Blockchain selber sind gerade 180 Gigabyte oder so. Es geht noch.
Oh, Gigabyte. Gut, okay.
Das ist ja noch im Rahmen. Ja, ich dachte alle Transaktionen mit allem drum und dran. Ja, also die Blockchain selber sind 180 Gigabyte, glaube ich gerade so.
Aber jedenfalls, naja, gut, es ist noch nicht perfekt. Also der eigentliche feuchte Traum von Krypto-Libertären und Anarchisten ist natürlich komplett untracebare, sozusagen digitales Bargeld.
Also es gibt halt jetzt Kryptowährungen, bei denen ist die Tracebarkeit hinreichend weit eingeschränkt, dass man davon ausgehen kann, dass das im Zweifel damit realisierbar wäre. Also wenn man halt irgendwie sowas wollte. Aber letztendlich haben alle eingesehen, dass es halt eine blöde Idee ist und deshalb macht es halt niemand. Also ich glaube, Assassination-Politik ist sowas wie Bioterrorismus. Also es ist halt irgendwie so ein intellektuelles Konzept, was erstmal furchterregend klingt, aber wo dann halt einfach am Ende halt irgendwie die...
Moment, ich wollte das jetzt auch nicht darstellen, als dass irgendwie die alle darauf hinarbeiten, Assassination-Politik umzusetzen. Nein, nein. Aber als Anforderungsliste an die Infrastruktur, die die gerne haben wollen, ist Assassination-Politik ganz gut geeignet, denn die möchten gern anonym kommunizieren können miteinander. Sie möchten aber trotzdem sich gegenseitig verifizieren können, wer der andere ist, aber nur sich selbst gegenüber, nicht dritten gegenüber. Und sie möchten gern am besten noch Zahlungen tätigen können. Das sind so die Anforderungen, die so ein typischer Krypto-Anarchist an die Infrastruktur hat. Und da sind wir sich verdammt nah dran.
Also die Technologie-Teile sind halt da. Das Problem ist halt nur, die sind natürlich alle im Perfekt. Also es gibt halt irgendwie genügend, naja, sagen wir mal, Software ist halt irgendwie im Perfekt. Es gibt halt irgendwie bei allem, was da jetzt gerade so passiert, irgendwie immer wieder technische Sicherheitsschwankungen, größeren Ausmaßes, werden jeden Tag irgendwelche Wallets und Exchanges aufgemacht und irgendwie Geld raus transferiert. Weil letztendlich ist es halt so, es sind halt tatsächlich wirklich Bits, die Geld sind. Also im Sinne von, wer diese Bits hat, hat halt das Geld. Also wenn du halt so ein Wallet in der Hand hast und die Passphrase dazu, dann hast du halt das Geld. Und dann kann halt auch wirklich niemand irgendwas dagegen tun. Also ist halt so, wenn du kannst hier halt einfach irgendwas anderes tauschen oder ausgeben. Und deswegen ist einer der interessanten Effekte, also für mich persönlich interessanten Effekte dieser Cryptocurrency-Geschichte, dass die jetzt halt so durch die Decken gehen ist, dass die Leute jetzt plötzlich anfangen ernsthaft in Sicherheit zu investieren. Also in so Offline-Wallets, zusätzliche Hardware, die du brauchst, um Transactions zu authentizieren. So diesen ganzen Kram, den Banken schon lange hätten mal machen sollen. Der passiert jetzt tatsächlich. Es gibt jetzt irgendwie einen ganzen Strauß voll von so externen Hardware-Token, die dir auf einem separaten Display anzeigen, irgendwie was jetzt die Transaktion ist, die du gerade mit dem Begriff bist zu tun, ob das denn okay ist. Irgendwie gibt es Leute, die investieren halt in sichere Software. Also es ist halt irgendwie so, diese ganze, also alles, wo es bisher so, naja Gott, irgendwie ein paar Euro vom Konto abräumen, interessiert halt keiner, investiert halt niemand in Sicherheit und plötzlich hast du Leute, unter anderem, weil es eine staatliche Garantie gibt.
Ja, aber jetzt hast du da Leute, die sitzen halt auf, die gibt es halt bei Krypto-Wirungen nicht.
Ja, literally halt irgendwie Dutzenden von Millionen Euro in irgendwelche Kryptocurrencies und das sind halt nur Bits auf ihrer Festplatte. So oder in ihrem...
Plötzlich wäre es wirklich scheiße, wenn die Platte einen Hardware-Effekt hat oder wenn jemand irgendwie mal dir einbricht und deine Bits klaut. So was. Bisher halt so, ja naja, ist halt passiert. Gut, aber ich glaube, du siehst das zu positiv.
Wieso?
Erstens, warum würdest du irgendeinem von diesen Geräten trauen wollen?
Na ja, trauen, wie soll ich sagen? Also ich meine, es geht ja bei IT-Security immer nur darum...
Nur ums Vertrauen. Das ist das einzige, worum es geht. Der Rest ist nämlich Schall und Rauch. Vertraust du dieser Technologie? Ja, warum?
Also es geht nur darum, dass es halt möglicherweise ein bisschen sportlicher für den Angreifer ist.
Woher weißt du denn, dass es nicht der Angreifer ist, der dir das Token verkauft hat?
Weißt du natürlich nicht, außer dass es ganz vielen anderen Leuten offensichtlich funktioniert hat. Und natürlich, ich meine, so viele von diesen Token sind halt irgendwie Bullshit. Da ist dann halt nur irgendwie so ein kleiner Arm drin. Und das Einzige, was es sicherer macht, ist, dass einfach die Code...
Trust-Zone.
Das die Code-Zone ist, also sozusagen die Angrussoberfläche halt irgendwie viel kleiner ist. Also, wie auch immer. Es gibt ja noch diesen ganzen großen Streit herum, welcher von diesen Coins jetzt halt irgendwie der, sozusagen derjenige wird, der dann halt es wird. Weil Bitcoin halt so unhandlich ist, also tatsächlich ist von damals irgendwie, wo man halt irgendwie tatsächlich noch seinen Burger mit Bitcoin kaufen konnte, wo man also dann mit dem Telefon so blieb blub und dann hat man halt seine Transaktion durch, hat halt irgendwie drei Minuten gedauert, sind halt mittlerweile bei irgendwie, wenn die Chain gerade ordentlich ausgelastet ist, halt so was wie halb einen Tag oder so, bis halt die Transaktion durch ist. Das heißt also auch der Wechselkurs zu dem, du dann halt verkaufst, ist halt irgendwie bei einer Volatilität von 4000 Dollar am Tag mehr so Glücksspiel. Deswegen gibt es halt auch nur eine Menge anderer Coins.
Das ist übrigens für mich der spannendste Aspekt daran. Ich bin ja so digitaler Katastrophentourist und guck mir so sehr volatile Felder mit ganz vielen neuen Marktteilnehmern guck ich mir immer gerne an. Und das fand ich also faszinierend, wie viele Leute dachten, sie können hier mal eben die schnelle Markt machen.
Und die schnelle Markt gemacht haben.
Ja, und haben die schnelle Markt gemacht. Es gibt ja inzwischen diese Initial Coin Offerings, die jetzt auch langsam anfangen, in den Zeitungen erwähnt zu werden.
Die sind jetzt mittlerweile schon so weit, dass man Taxifahrer nicht gefragt hat, ob man in den ICO investieren soll. Wir sind schon am...
Und du hast gesagt, nein, das ist der...
Am Bubble platzen.
Genau, das ist so der, wie hieß es, wenn die BILD Zeitung darüber schreibt und dich dein Taxifahrer darauf anspricht, steig aus, ja, dann ist die Bubble gerade am Blasen. Nein, aber der Punkt ist, das ist sozusagen eine Sache, die die Start-ups machen können, um schnell Geld zu drucken und zwar sozusagen als Crowdsourcing von den Leuten, die doof genug sind, ihnen ihre Coins irgendwie abzukaufen, die sie gerade selbst erfunden haben. Und nicht von irgendwelchen Investoren, die ihnen möglicherweise mit geballter Marktmacht irgendwie dann den Nacken runterpusten, weil sie irgendwelche Geschäftsziele erreicht haben wollen. Das wird also gesehen als Vehikel für einen Start-up, um Kapital ran zu schaffen. Und das ist also ein Metagame, was da gespielt wird. Und ich habe überhaupt nicht verstanden, was für Leute bei solchen ICOs mitmachen, bis ich dann mal so einen Artikel gelesen habe von einem Typ in Nigeria, der meinte, er sucht immer den ICO, der heute Morgen erfunden wurde. Weil er sich da sicher sein kann, dass irgendwie die Blase erstmal ein bisschen... Das geht erstmal hoch. Ja, aber so also, das heißt, das ist reines Gezocke. Das hat nichts mit, ich investiere jetzt in diese Firma oder Kapital, sondern das ist reines Gezocke zwischen lauter Marktteilnehmern, denen auch allen bewusst ist, dass sie da zocken. Also das ist so eine Schlangengrube, die sich alle gegenseitig zu fressen versuchen. Und das ist sozusagen die Antithese davon, was ich unter Investment verstehe. Aber ich kann nachvollziehen, warum die Leute da investieren. Das sind halt so Glücksrittergeschichten.
Naja, also ich meine, diese ICO ist an sich ja eigentlich keine so doofe Idee, wenn man...
Naja, also ich mein, man kann auch andersrum sagen, das ist eine Errungenschaft, was wir inzwischen für Regulierungen haben, damit die Start-ups nicht einfach Leute verarschen. Und dann schnell zusammenfalten, wenn die Polizei kommt. Das gilt, ja, das haben wir ausgegeben, tut uns leid. Also das wird ja alles, alle Regulierungserrungenschaften, und es dauert ja 10, 20 Jahre, bis irgendein so ein Ding mal ordentlich reguliert wird, nachdem es die fette Katastrophe gab. Ja, all diese Sachen, die sind ja bei diesen neuen Krypto-Geschichten noch völlig unreguliert bei den Märkten. Und das kann man natürlich, wenn man so ein Rand irgendwie Turbo-Kapitalist ist, kann man das total geil finden. Guck mal, hier funktionieren die ganzen alten Tricks noch. Aber als Investor ist das halt scheiße. Also wenn du so Day-Trader irgendwie Zocker bist, ist das bestimmt total adrenalinepumpend. Aber also ich kann nur sagen, investiert da kein Geld, wo euch irgendwie zwicken würde, wenn das weg ist. Weil das ist keine gute Idee.
Genau, wo wir wieder beim Geld sind.
Eigentlich wollten wir noch diesen anderen Moment erwähnen, den es vor kurzem gab, als nämlich der Bitcoin-Blasenfaktor zur größten Blase in der Geschichte der Menschheit geworden ist, weil es nämlich die bisher größte Blase überholt hat.
Genau, und zwar die bisherige größte Blase, was den Faktor Steigerung pro Zeiteinheit anging, war nach allem, was wir wissen, der Amsterdamer Tulpenmarkt.
Das war auch die erste große Blase.
Das war nicht die erste große Blase. Da gab es noch andere.
Ach, erzähl, ich hab keine gefunden.
Da gab es noch andere große Blasen. Es gibt da ein Buch, was wir mal wieder empfehlen müssen.
Als erste relativ gute umetische Spekulationsblase der Wirtschaftsgeschichte angesehen, schreibt Wikipedia.
Na gut, 1637. Das war relativ früh. Stimmt, ja. Also von der Zeit her war es wahrscheinlich doch mit so die erste große. Also es gibt da noch ein schönes Buch, was wir tatsächlich immer mal wieder empfehlen müssen.
Das Wikipedia-Stichwort heißt Tulpen-Money, ein sehr langer Artikel. Also es geht im Wesentlichen darum, dass Tulpen-Anbau, sozusagen der, eins der Export- und Luxusgüter-Schlager war derzeit. So reiche, privilegierte Leute haben Tulpen in ihrem Garten gehabt und Tulpen-Zwiebeln waren also echt, das waren was wert, ja. Und dann gab es eine Spekulationsblase, die sich gebildet hat im Rahmen derer dann plötzlich alle möglichen Leute Schulden gemacht haben, um sich davon Tulpen-Zwiebeln zu kaufen, unter der Annahme, dass die später mehr wert sein werden.
Und sie wurden ja auch überall.
Und es hat auch funktioniert, wie das so ist mit Blasen. Das funktioniert eine Weile super. Außer du bist der, der am Ende irgendwie mit einem Sack voller Tulpen-Zwiebeln da sitzt und alle gucken dich an und sagen, der hat ja gar keine Kleider an, der Kaiser. Dann ist halt scheiße. Tja, und der Preis ist also so krass geworden, dass irgendwann sah es so aus, als wenn die gesamte Wirtschaft implodieren könnte. Und dann sind sie zum Monarchen gegangen. Und der hat gesagt, Leute, das sind Tulpen-Zwiebeln. Nein, ich mache jetzt hier keine irgendwie Ausnahmeregelung. Selber schuld. Und das war das.
Also da gibt es da gibt es so schöne Geschichten. Also als die als das war, sozusagen Bailout, den die haben wollten, die reichen Händler und der Monarch hat gesagt, da gab es dann so Geschichten, wie das ein berittener Boote, der halt irgendwie nicht so viel davon wusste, kam halt irgendwie zum, also wohl vom Hafen mit der neuen Ladung Zwiebeln.
Ach und wie das ritt, hat sich der Preis irgendwie?
Nee, und der kam halt von außerhalb und der hat dann halt irgendwie als Lohn dafür, dass er so schnell war und halt die Spiegel auf der Mittelfeld hat halt eine Tulpenzwiebel bekommen und hat die halt für normale Zwiebel gehalten und die sich zum Hering aufs Brot gesteckt.
Und da hätte man für den Preis einen Haus von Graupen gelegt.
Ja, so ein Fuhrwerk mit zwei Verfehlen, zwei Verfehlen.
Ja, also die Tulpen sind jetzt nicht mehr die größte Blase, sondern Bitcoin ist jetzt die größte Blase.
Genau, also es gibt da halt ein sehr empfehlenswertes Buch zu. Da haben wir noch eine Liste von John Kenneth Galbraith, eine kurze Geschichte der Spekulation. Das ist so der Klassiker, was irgendwie so die Dinge angeht, wenn halt irgendwie die Blasen mal wieder anfangen, sich aufzupumpen. Also er hat natürlich halt über alle möglichen Spekulationen geschrieben. Also Tulpen und Holland, den Louisiana Gold Boom, Immobilienwurm in Florida auch irgendwie ganz krass. Also es ist ein sehr unterhaltsames kleines Buch, was man mal so kurz sich so neben seinen Bitcoin legen kann. Das ist auf jeden Fall so.
Also es gibt ja Wirtschaftsbeobachter, die behaupten, dass die Wirtschaft nur noch aus Blasen besteht, weil der Wachstumszeitraum vorbei ist.
Ja, das ist wahrscheinlich richtig.
Und da ist nicht völlig von anzuweisen. Also wir haben auch im Moment um uns rum diverse Blasen. Der Immobilienmarkt ist auch in Deutschland eine Blase, der gerade der Markt für Kommerzimmobilien ist schon mehrfach irgendwie in diversen Städten voll vor die Wand gefahren.
Also Geschäftsräume und so ein Kran?
Ja, ja. Büroräume. Ja, und in England ist es auch ganz krass mit den Immobilien. Und was für so eine Blase halt immer total super ist, ist, wenn es irgendeine externe Kraft gibt, die verhindert, dass das Angebot steigt. Und das gibt es halt bei Bitcoin und es gibt es bei Immobilien. Daher blasen das so gut.
Naja, und?
Die besten Blasen, die man für Geld kaufen kann.
Ja gut, ich meine, bei Cryptocurrencies gibt es natürlich noch so andere Effekte, wie das halt, also die Möglichkeit, tatsächlich auszustrengen, ist halt stark begrenzt, weil irgendwie, man guckt ja immer, also man handelt ja nicht mit den Leuten weltweit, sondern halt immer nur mit denen, die halt irgendwie auf derselben Exchange sind, mit denen man halt unterwegs ist. Und daraus folgt dann halt, dass die Menge an Geld, die man da halt irgendwie so durchschieben kann, ist halt irgendwie stark begrenzt. Das ist also auch die...
Perfekt für eine Blasenbildung.
Und es heißt halt also, dadurch, dass die Transaktionen so lange dauern, ist halt, was man normalerweise in so einem Markt erwartet, ist halt so eine Art Arbitrage. Das heißt also, die Preise gleichen sich aus zwischen den einzelnen Exchanges. Wenn der Preis an einer viel zu hoch ist, an einer viel zu niedrig, dann kaufen die halt an einer einen, verkaufen an einer anderen. So was halt so ein typisches, so ein Arbitrage-Geschäft machen, Aktienhändler den ganzen Tag irgendwie so mit.
Ist vor allem das Brot und Butter von so diesen ursprünglich von den Daytradern gewesen.
Genau. Und damit, also die Erfüllende mit durchaus auch ein Zweck, die sorgen halt dafür, dass es halt ein relativ, also das ist so eine Liquidität im Markt bleibt.
Das ist, du fieser, neoliberaler, wie Marktapologeet. Das ist genau die eine Entschuldigung, die man immer hört, warum es gut ist, Spekulanten im Markt zu haben. Die sorgen dafür, dass es Volatilität gibt.
Also Abitrage, also Abitrage ist halt schon so. Es gibt ja viele Formen der Spekulation, wie zum Beispiel so Futures und so, wo ich halt irgendwie echt nicht mitgehe, dass die irgendwie einen sinnvollen Zweck haben. Liquidität nicht Volatilität. Also Derivate, da hab ich keine, keine...
Ja, das ist doch jetzt, erklär das doch mal. Das ist doch jetzt der neueste, der neueste...
Derivate auf Bitcoin, genau. Es gibt jetzt Futures auf Bitcoin.
Warum ist das relevant? Also, die gibt's ja schon länger, die Derivate eigentlich.
Das ist, was ist...
Das Neue ist, dass die jetzt an einer traditionellen Börse gehandelt werden.
Man kann jetzt an einer traditionellen Börse ohne sein Geld in Bitcoin zu tun, in Bitcoin spekulieren. Das heißt also, man kann halt also hingehen, sagen so, ich spekuliere auf, dass der Bitcoin-Kurs weiter steigt und kauft eine Wette darauf, dass der Bitcoin-Kurs steigt. Diese Wette wird halt ausfällig außerhalb der Blockchain ausgeführt in den traditionellen Zockerbankensystemen, also so wie man halt auf den weitesten Preis wetten kann. Also da kamen ja ursprünglich diese Futures her. Diese Futures waren ja ganz ursprünglich in ihrer ursprünglichen Geschichte ein Vehikel, um Bauern die Möglichkeit zu geben, schon mal Geld für ihre noch nicht eingebrachte Ernte zu kriegen und damit sie halt irgendwie ja schon mal wirtschaften konnten. Das heißt, die haben halt ihre Ernte vorwärts zu einem Preis verkauft. Und dann hatte quasi der Händler, der dieses Angebot angenommen hat, hatte einen Schein in der Hand, da steht drauf, ich kann am 30. September 500 Tonnen Weizen dieser Qualität für diesen Preis kaufen. Und dann haben die angefangen damit zu handeln, mit diesen Zetteln. Also mit Sachen, die sie noch nicht im Speicher hatten.
Ging das von den Bauern aus? Ich dachte, das ging von den Händlern aus.
Das ging von den Mühlenbesitzern aus.
Ah, ich hab das nämlich ganz anders verstanden.
Den Leuten, die die Kornspeicher und die... Die haben denen einfach dieses Angebot gemacht. Also dieses Auf-Kredit-Kaufen gab es halt in den...
Ja, warte mal, das sind doch aber die Händler. Also die Leute, die von den Bauern kaufen.
Nee, also die Bauern, also die... Also ganz am Anfang war es so, dass die Leute, die halt so die normalen Stores betrieben haben, also normalen Läden. Und die Bauern waren halt nicht liquide im Sommer, weil sie halt noch nicht die Kohle von der Ernte drin haben. Also haben sie anschreiben lassen. Und irgendwann haben sie dann halt den Getreide anschreiben lassen. Also sozusagen in zwei Tonnen Getreide für irgendwie was Fleisch, was ich gerade noch kaufen muss, oder Waschmittel.
Kriegst du, sobald es geerntet ist?
Kriegst du, sobald geerntet ist. Und daraus hat sich das dann entwickelt. Es gibt dann ein ganz großartiges Buch, das heißt Nature's Metropolis. Hab ich euch bestimmt schon mal empfohlen, aber es ist irgendwie...
Ich glaube nicht...
.muss ich nochmal empfehlen, wo dieses... Kannst du mal ein Pils machen, dass wir das mit in die Liste tun? Wo die Entstehung dieser Kommodifizierung von, ja, Naturprodukten erläutert wird. Also wie es halt dazu kam, dass halt die Getreide halt irgendwie zu einem handelbaren Gut wurde, obwohl es noch gar nicht vorhanden war, und Schweinehilfen und alles andere und Holz. Und irgendwann gab es halt diese Spaltung bei diesen Naturprodukten und zwar gab es dann halt die Contracts for delivery. Das heißt, ich will wirklich meine Schweinehilfen haben, weil ich will daraus irgendwie Wurst machen und die not for delivery. Ich zocke hier bloß. Ich will irgendwie nur einfach auf den Preis spekulieren. Und da trennte sich dann halt so dieser, also das war für mich so der Zeitpunkt, wo halt diese ganzen Futures anfingen halt nur noch Bullshit zu sein und irgendwie, irgendwie mit dem System nichts mehr zu tun zu haben und einfach nur noch dem System zu schaden.
Ja, aber so kam ich ja darauf, die, wenn du heute einen Ökonomen fragst, was denn die Daseinsberechtigung für Futures ist und für so Gezocke, dann sagen die, sagen die Hedging? Ja, Moment, for delivery, okay, aber ich sagen auch Hedging. Also das heißt, du kannst sozusagen, wenn du, ich sag mal in Aktien oder in tatsächlichen Wertpapieren darauf spekulierst, dass es nach oben geht, kannst du auch eine Wette darauf abschließen, dass es nach unten geht, die dann, wenn du dich verzockt hast, ein Teil deiner Verluste auffängt. Ja, also sozusagen als Versicherung. Das wird immer genannt und es wird genannt, dass Optionen ein Instrument sind für Liquidität schaffen. Und das ist ein krasses Argument, weil wenn man sich anguckt, wie viel die Anteile sind, wie viel Kohle in in Derivaten gehandelt wird und wie viel in tatsächlichen Produkten. Da liegen Größenordnungen dazwischen. Also so Faktor 1000 aufwärts. Das ist absolut unglaublich. Hat nichts mit der Realität zu tun, was die da zocken.
Also man deswegen, solange es halt Bitcoin ist, Bitcoin zu bewegen, den Preis, muss man jetzt schon Geld investieren, aber jetzt auch nicht so gigantische Mengen. Also für...
Warte mal, wir müssen noch erklären, was denn jetzt die Auswirkung ist, wenn an der regulären... Naja, so regulär ist jetzt auch eher so eine... Chicago, was war das? Ich hab so ganz vergessen, welcher Action. Ja, aber jedenfalls nicht Nasdaq, oder? Also das heißt, aber es ist, dadurch, dass es an einer regulären Börse gehandelt wird, können jetzt institutionelle Investoren, so Fondanbieter, können da jetzt investieren. Und je nachdem, wie man draufguckt, vereint das sozusagen die Vor- oder die Nachteile. Ja, also ich kann jetzt zocken und bin nicht abhängig von diesen Verrückten in China.
Es gibt halt das Problem dabei, dass der...
Aber es heißt auch, ich hab halt keine Bitcoin in der Hand, sondern ich handel hier im Grunde mit irgendwas handeln.
Du hast eine Wette.
Ich völlig wurscht, was da runterkommt.
Du hast eine Wette abgeschlossen.
Es gibt Zocke.
Mit dem Unterschied, dass du bei solchen Futures gibt's halt so eine oder zwei Taktiken, mit denen du versuchen kannst, diesen Preis zu beeinflussen. Eine davon ist so das Market Cornering.
Willst du die Porsche Story mal erzählen? Die ist ja jetzt auch schon ein paar Jahre wieder her.
Die kriege ich aus dem Kopf nicht mehr ganz zusammen. Weißt du die noch? So grob.
Es ging irgendwie darum, dass...
Ich kann sie mal am Basis von Weizen erzählen.
Genau, erklär mal von Weizen.
Genau. Da funktioniert es halt so, dass du, wenn du alle, also es gibt Optionen am Markt, die für einen bestimmten Preis, es gibt halt irgendwie eine Sorte Weizen, roter Winterweißen, irgendwie erste Güteklasse, von dem weißt du, wird in der Regel nur eine bestimmte Menge geerntet. Also da fallen keine Ahnung, in einem bestimmten Gebiet, in einem bestimmten Jahr, fallen davon nur keine Ahnung, 200.000 Tonnen an. Und was du jetzt halt tun kannst, ist du kannst den versuchen, diese Optionen, die du dafür rausgibst oder die du dafür kaufst, zu monopolisieren und den Preis nach oben zu treiben. Das heißt, das ist in dem Umblick, wo du halt den alles, was irgendwie an For-Delivery-Weizen ist, also wenn du sozusagen all die Rechte für diese ganzen 200.000 Tonnen Weizen unter der Hand gesichert hast, aber da sind da draußen noch Leute, die müssen, die haben Optionen verkauft und die müssen diesen Weizen liefern an die Leute, denen sie diese Optionen verkauft haben, dann müssen die bei dir zum quasi billigigen Preis kaufen, weil die müssen ihren Vertrag raffeln.
Das ist so ein bisschen die Mafiamethode. Wenn du weißt, die Stadt will eine Brücke bauen und du kaufst allen Zement auf und du weißt, die müssen bei dir kaufen, weil der gesamte Zement, den Skript, den hast du, dann kannst du den Preis diktieren. Das ist eigentlich so. Aber der Punkt ist, dadurch, dass...
Das ist halt eine Methode des Market Cornerings.
Genau, das ist halt Market Cornering. Aber dadurch, dass jetzt die Optionsscheine dabei sind, wissen die Teilnehmer gar nicht, mit wem sie da handeln und wer die anderen sind. Und bei dieser Porsche-Geschichte ging es darum, dass die Optionsscheine auf VW gekauft haben, wenn ich mich recht in Sinne von Leuten, die nicht damit gerechnet haben, dass jemand die einlösen will. Und irgendwann kam dann raus, dass sie sozusagen, ich weiß nicht, ob es mehr Rechte an Aktien gekauft haben, als es Aktien gab, weil einfach Leute, ob Wetten verkauft haben, in dem sozusagen, in der Gewissheit, dass niemand das würde einlösen wollen. Und dann hat es aber doch jemand eingelöst. Und dann mussten die halt zu jedem Preis kaufen. Und plötzlich ging der Wert der unterliegenden Security, in diesem Fall die VW-Aktien, ging halt hoch. Und das war im Grunde auch Market Connering. Aber der Punkt ist eben, das ist eigentlich, wo man so sagen würde, vom Rechtsgefühl her grenzkriminell. Wenn du irgendwie Leute nötigst, Sachen zu einem beliebigen Preis zu kaufen, den du diktieren kannst, indem du halt den kompletten Markt irgendwie gekauft hast.
Also ich vermute, dass sowas halt irgendwie passieren wird, sobald es Optionen auf kleinere Cryptocurrencies gibt. Also, wenn man jetzt mal so guckt, wie viel halt jetzt irgendwie so in Bitcoin gehandelt wird, dann ist, also was haben wir da heute? Wir können ja gerade mal nachgucken, so live und in Farbe haben wir hier heute ein Handelsvolumen von 12 Milliarden Dollar, die halt in Bitcoin gehandelt werden. Also relativ wenig. Gab schon Tage, da wurde signifikant mehr gehandelt. Die 24-Stunden-Volumen von allen Cryptocurrency sind gerade so 30 Milliarden Dollar, die da halt so hergeschoben werden. Und das ist aus der Perspektive von jemand, der professionell zockt an der Börse, ein sehr überschaubarer Betrag.
Genug, als dass mal jemand so ein Fond genug Kohle irgendwie als Spekulationsvolumen pro Tag hat, um Market Cornering zu machen.
Oder um, dadurch, dass es ja der Markt so fragmentiert ist, also an den vielen Exchanges, ist halt die kritische Frage, ist wie ist denn eigentlich dieser...
Es reicht auf einem Exchange den Markt zu cornern, meinst du?
Nee, die Frage ist halt, wie ist der Future definiert? Also welcher Preis liegt diesem Future zugrunde? Liegt der eine Exchange zugrunde oder erdurch und von mehreren Exchanges? Und wenn, also aber selbst wenn es mehrere Exchanges sind, ist das Marktvolumen, was da gehandelt wird, trotzdem immer noch so klein, dass mit einem, mit genug Investment dieser Markt tatsächlich irgendwie zu bewegen ist. Und das ist so attraktiv für die da dran, dass sie halt einfach, dass also für die großen Fische da dran, dass sie halt damit in der Lage sind, halt irgendwie den Markt dahin zu bewegen, wo ihre Futures sind.
Und und solange das nach oben ist, sind auch alle total zufrieden. Aber also man sollte vielleicht noch sagen, einer der Kriegsschauplätze im Moment ist die Frage, wie man denn Bitcoin einschätzen soll. Ist das eine Währung oder ist das ein Investmentvehikel? Also und da gibt es eine Aufsichtsbehörde in den USA, die da jetzt sogar nachgedacht hat, wie sie das einschätzen sollen. Und was davon abhängt, ist unter anderem die Frage, was für Regulierungen gelten für die Handelsplätze. Und das ist schon relevant, denn so Sachen wie Insider-Trading sind nur unter Strafe gestellt für Sachen, die als Investments gelten. Und es gibt so diverse Tricks, die Banken machen können oder Aktienbroker machen können, um sich selbst zu bereichern. Ich sage jetzt mal als Beispiel, ein Fond kommt und will 100.000 VW-Aktien kaufen oder was weiß ich, ist ja egal. Und der Fond sieht diese Order, weil die halt bei ihnen in System ist und kauft dann selber ein paar Aktien erst mal für sich, macht dann diese fette Order, die den Preis hochtreibt und verkauft dann die wieder, die sie vorher gekauft hat. Das nennt sich Frontrunning. Ja, das ist so einer der...
Damit ist Goldman Sachs groß geworden.
Ja, also diese Art von Sachen sind eigentlich reguliert und verboten. Und na klar.
Frontrunning ist, also die Frontrunning-Regulierung ist so fisch, die wird nicht ordentlich umgesetzt.
Da sind wir voll, sind wir uns einig. Aber auf dem Papier ist es verboten. Und wenn du jemanden dabei erwischst, dass der das macht, kannst du theoretisch empfindliche Strafen gegen den Fank kriegen. Aber bei Bitcoin gibt es halt nicht mal die Regulierung. Das heißt, das ist noch eine Stufe, noch eine Stufe gefährlicher. Das heißt, die müssen überhaupt keine Zurückhaltung haben, dich zu verarschen.
Ja, also da ist es halt so, dass die Exchanges halt sehr unterschiedliche Policies fahren. Es gibt halt auch welche, die so, also die sich da am allergrößten möglichen Transparenz bemühen. Also wo du halt einfach dir den kompletten Feed einmal raw geben kannst und siehst, wann dein Trade reingekippt wurde, zu welchem Ding er ausgeführt wurde, was für andere Trades gleichzeitig passiert sind. Also es ist halt dann...
Aber da kannst du auch sehen, dass das dann irgendwie eine Stunde gedauert hat zwischen reinkippen und landet im Feed. Und dann? Was machst du dann?
Genau, dann hast du halt...
Na, ist nicht so, dass es da beliebig viele Exchanges gibt.
Na, es gibt schon eine Menge Exchanges, und es gibt auch durchaus Exchanges, die nicht öffentlich anbieten, sondern die halt nur private sind.
Das ist ja noch beschissen, oder?
Noch unregulierter.
Wilder Westen.
Ist halt wie Dark Pools, ne? Also, wie auch immer, wir haben uns da was überlegt.
Und zwar, Frank hat sich was überlegt. Ich war schon bei der Hände in der Noten schuld.
Und zwar ist ja sozusagen die große Frage ist, irgendwie welcher Coin ist denn eigentlich der beste? Also ist jetzt Bitcoin oder ist es Monere oder Bitcoin Cash oder Z-Cash oder Bitcoin Gold? Oder was haben wir noch? Dash oder Jota oder was auch immer?
Von Jota habe ich jetzt ein paar echt vernichtende Zusammenfassungen gehört.
Ja, die Mathematik ist nicht überall gleich gut. Jedenfalls, was wir machen werden, ist, wir werden euch demnächst die Option offerieren, dass ihr uns Spenden halt in allen den Coins eurer Wahl geben könnt. Und wir treffen dann in zwölf Monaten die Entscheidung, welcher Coin der beste Coin ist.
Also Frank möchte eigentlich über Crowdsourcing herausfinden, welches die guten Währungen sind.
Genau. Und da es ja schwierig ist, irgendwie wie wir also dir auszurechnen, welches jetzt irgendwie der tollste Coin ist, wenn man irgendwie keinen Referenzwert hat. Weil vierte Manne geht natürlich gar nicht. Das sieht man ja vollkommen ein. Wären wir das Goldkurs nehmen.
Er ist zwar auch manipuliert, aber...
Aber der ist stabil im Vergleich zu einer anderen.
Der wird von unseren Leuten manipuliert. Nein, warte.
Das waren die anderen. Gut, also ihr kennt ja dieses, ihr habt ja vielleicht mal sehen, dieses Bild von diesem einen Bettler, ich glaube in Kalifornien. Der hat dieses Prinzip erfunden. Er hat gesagt, okay, pass auf. Wir wollen herausfinden, welche Religion ist die wohltätigste Religion. Er hat halt einen Becher aufgestellt für jede Religion. Er hat gesagt, hier sind Christen oder Juden oder Moslems oder irgendwie hat er die Christen nochmal aufgespalten in die verschiedenen Kirchen mit Buddhism und so. Und hat gesagt, so am Ende des Tages guckt er halt, welche Religion ist die wohltätigste, indem er einfach zählt, wie viel Dollar in welchem Becher sind. Und wir machen das genau dasselbe spielen, sagen wir finden heraus, welcher Coin der beste ist, indem wir gucken, in welchem Wallet in zwölf Monaten am meisten liegt. Und dann haben wir unsere Auswertung. Wurde es dann in ein paar Tagen auf der Webseite geben. Ja, apropos Geld, da versuchen wir gerade noch so eine Regierungsbildung irgendwie.
Ich hab die ja immer als schwarz-gelb beschrieben, als es noch schwarz-gelb war. Das fing an als freudschaffer Tippern und habe ich es beibehalten, weil ich es einfach so gut fand.
Das hat er sich dann auch, hat er dann auch tatsächlich verpachtet.
Das hat dann so ein Eigenleben auch gekriegt. Ja, ja, eines Tages hat auch bei der Tagesschau sich jemand strategisch vertippt, wenn ich es mal bezeichne. Ja, aber es geht natürlich auch bei der Regierungsbildung um Geld und das beobachten wir auch so ein bisschen aus der Ferne und um Reputation. Und wir haben leider verkackt, jetzt hier so einen Popcorn MP3 mitzubringen.
Stellt euch Popcorn MP3 vor, ihr könnt es euch ja...
Wir beobachten das, als wären wir nicht betroffen. Das ist glaube ich die einzige Methode, auf wie man das machen kann.
Also was mich daran halt so fasziniert ist, dass die SPD sich quasi selber in so diese Situation von diesem Frosch im Topf mit dem wärmer werdenden Wasser begeben hat. Von auf gar keinen Fall. Und wir denken da nicht mal drüber nach. Und es kommt überhaupt nicht in die Tüte. Weil also was wir...
Vorsicht, Vorsicht. Es gibt die Verschwörungstheorie, dass die SPD hier der schlauste Aktor ist.
Das müsstest du jetzt aber ein bisschen ausführlicher erklären, weil die Annahme ist jetzt nicht so...
Ja, fand ich faszinierend. So nach dem Motto, die SPD tut am Anfang so, als seien sie moralisch getrieben und gehen in die Opposition, weil sonst die AfD die stärkste Oppositionspartei ist und die Führung der Opposition übernimmt. Also sie haben einen guten Vorwand. Und dann wissen sie, dass alle Jamaika und sonst was Optionen scheitern werden und sind sozusagen der Fallback, zu dem die CDU genau dann geht, wenn es komplett vor die Wand gefahren ist und wenn sie die Bedingungen vorgeben können. Was sie dann natürlich nicht tun, weil es halt die SPD ist. Aber so nach dem Motto, eigentlich kein Doverplan. Wenn es irgendeinen Anlass dafür gäbe, der SPD diese Art von Bauernschleue und Taktik zuzutrauen, fände ich es ja eigentlich nicht schlecht. Ich meine, ich fände es ja gut, wenn wir hier mal zumindest einen Teilnehmer in der Politik hätten, der mehr als aussitzen kann. So als Strategie. Aber es wirkt halt alles so ein bisschen, ich weiß nicht, als wenn es so die erste Regierungsbildung ist, die die machen. Ich meine, seit 16 Jahren oder was steht das an der Wand, dass es demnächst hier nicht mehr weitergeht mit Durchregieren und jedes Mal haben die dann doch noch irgendwie durchregiert. Und jetzt geht es halt nicht mehr und alle so, oh, da sind wir jetzt nicht darauf vorbereitet.
Was mich ja da so ein bisschen dran erstaunt ist, dass die SPD eigentlich so sich in den Nachbarländern sehr gut angucken kann, wie weit nach unten es für sozial-demokratische Parteien gehen kann. Also von den normalen Niederländer, wo halt die Mehrheitsverhältnisse schon mal relativ ähnlich waren wie hier, und die Sozialdemokraten sind glaube ich jetzt bei 6% oder 7% oder so. Und die waren halt auch immer zu in der Regierung und irgendwie so waren wir aber über 30% und so und jetzt sind sie bei so 6-7% und da scheint auch keine Grenze nach unten zu sein, wie so in anderen Ländern, so ähnlich in Österreich gerade, irgendwie ähnliches Spiel, wo halt also klar ist, dass die Sozialdemokraten sich da halt irgendwie auch so weit verfülzt und versemmelt haben, dass es halt also überhaupt nicht mehr ging und sie jetzt halt eine richtig rechte Regierung haben, also quasi naja.
Also geradezu schockierend, also nicht nur rechts, sondern halt so auch richtig so tumme Populistenrechts, ja so völlig transparenter Populismus, nicht mal, die tun nicht mal so, als sei das was anderes. Also ich bin ja immer, ich weiß nicht, ich hab irgendwie den Anspruch, zumindest ordentlich belogen zu werden. Ich möchte gern das Gefühl haben, dass die sich Mühe geben, wenn sie mir ins Gesicht lügen, aber das gibt es halt nicht mehr. Also es gibt da so einen Trend. Also die einfache Erklärung ist natürlich, die Sozialdemokraten sind einfach Fehler gemacht. Weil sie immer Junior-Partner in der Koalition waren und haben nicht gemerkt, dass das eigentlich die mächtige Hälfte der Koalition ist. Denn vom Senior-Partner erwartet man, dass er die Entscheidung trifft, aber der Junior-Partner kann immer Ja und Nein sagen. Das heißt, der bestimmt eigentlich, wo es langgeht. Der Senior-Partner kann nicht sagen, ich habe keinen Bock mehr, kann nur die Koalition aufkündigen. Aber der Junior-Partner kann sich anstellen, wie ein ungezogenes kleines Kind. Aber das haben die halt nie gemacht, haben ihre Macht nie ausgenutzt. Und die CDU hat das aber, glaube ich, gesehen und hat einen Trend vorangetrieben, dass jetzt in den Koalitionsverträgen nicht mehr die Richtung vorgegeben wird, sondern bis zum Wording der Gesetze, die man zusammen machen will. Wird da schon alles festgeschrieben. Und dann muss man sich fragen, wieso machen wir denn überhaupt noch die vier Jahre Politik?
Das war in Holland übrigens ähnlich. Da war es halt auch so, dass die, weil denn alle Koalitionen im Wesentlichen nur noch die ohne Wilders waren. Also es war halt der einzige gemeinsame Nenner der Koalition, da war halt mit ohne Wilders. Und die waren sich aber so uneinig über das, was sie eigentlich tun wollten, dass sie genau alles aufgeschrieben haben.
Aber das ist doch eigentlich gut.
Das ist doch Politik. Na darüber hinaus ging es halt auch nicht mehr. Aber daraus folgte dann halt eben das, wenn irgendwas Überraschendes passierte.
Na aber was heißt ging nicht? Was heißt denn geht das? Das finde ich absolut ein Non-Sequitor an der Stelle. Was heißt hier geht nicht? Das ist Politik. Irgendwas passiert und du reagierst darauf.
Ja, aber...
Komm mal, im Moment sind wir doch...
Aber es ging dann halt nicht mehr, weil die sich nicht einig waren, weil sie keine politische Richtung hatten.
Na dann muss man halt diskutieren, verdammt noch mal.
Na das haben sie dann halt getan und sie wurden sich halt nicht einig. Sie konnten nicht reagieren.
Dann gibt es halt keine...
Nein, nein, sie waren nicht mehr reaktionsfähig. Na und das führte halt dazu, also das Tatsächlich, so Handeln einer Regierung. Also normalerweise kannst du ja sagen, okay, so lang regiert sich selber die Beamten. Machen das schon, wenn die da zu viel rumregieren, wird sowieso alles nur schlechter. Aber in dem Augenblick, wo dann tatsächlich mal was passieren musste, weil man ein neues Problem erkannt hat, während der Periode oder wenn halt irgendwas wichtiger wurde, waren die halt dazu kaum in der Lage.
Und obendrein stellte sich halt das Gefühl ein, dass das nicht bereit ist, einfach hinzunehmen, dass es dann so ist, sondern das ist dann ein Versagen.
Der Mechanismus, den wir halt in Niederland beobachten können.
Ja, aber das ist ein Versagen der Aktoren in den Niederlanden. Dann die haben dann aktiv das Ding vor die Wand gefahren, weil sie gesagt haben, ich sehe lieber das Land untergehen, bevor ich hier ein Kompromiss angehe.
Am Ende haben sie dann häufiger noch schlechte Kompromisse gemacht oder die Regierung ist geplatzt, häufig genug. Das passiert dann auch immer wieder.
Da hab ich auch kein Problem mit. Ist dann halt so.
Da gab es dann halt Neuwahlen. Und jedes Mal ist das stärker geworden. Und was da halt passierte, war halt so ein Mechanismus.
Ich kriege hier schon wieder Bluthochdruck.
Nee, aber was passiert?
Ich finde, hier wird auch wieder Ursache und Wirkung verwechselt.
Ich schreibe erst mal nur den Mechanismus. Der Mechanismus ist halt einfach, dass wenn die anderen Parteien nicht in der Lage sind, eine politische Vision zu vermitteln und immer nur den Eindruck machen, dass sie halt primär reagieren, also dass sie sich die Themen setzen lassen, also dass sie halt nicht in der Lage sind, eine eigene Agenda zu entwickeln, eine positive Vision zu entwickeln, irgendwas zu entwickeln, was halt so dieser tummen Ausländerfeindlichkeit irgendwas entgegensetzt, dann führt es halt dazu, dass sie von so Leuten wie Wilders dann halt vor sich hergetrieben werden. Deutschland dann halt die AfD. An dieser Stelle in der politischen Entwicklung sind wir jetzt gerade auch, dass diese Gefahr droht, dass wir also halt eine Regierung haben werden, die im Wesentlichen aus Angst vor der AfD besteht, also die halt nicht mal irgendwie eine eigene politische Agenda hat.
Aber das ist ja schon länger so. Das kann man ja schon seit Jahren beobachten. Da ist die im Grunde alle nur noch.
In Deutschland war es halt bisher so, dadurch, dass die AfD nicht im Bundestag war, war halt zwar vorhanden, aber noch nicht konkret. Und jetzt ist es halt konkret. Ja. Und das reduziert halt die Koalitionsoptionen und führt halt dazu, dass jetzt der eigentliche Schritt, der jetzt getan werden müsste, nämlich zu sagen, wir entwickeln eigene politische Visionen und wir suchen uns halt die Mehrheiten dafür, indem wir zum Beispiel halt auch mal mit den anderen Parteien reden. Also warum gibt es kein Rot-Grün-Links? Theoretisch, also es gibt im Bundestag gerade keine Mehrheit dafür, aber zumindest, wenn die sich mal zusammenraufen würden, sagen würden, wir machen mal eine Vision, wir bauen mal ein Programm auf zusammen und sagen, wir wollen irgendwie mehr Gerechtigkeit, wir wollen halt irgendwie die Probleme angehen, wir wollen halt nicht nur irgendwie mit der Weiterkohle von unten nach oben umverteilen.
Da macht man halt eine Minderheitsregierung. Ich weiß nicht, was das Problem damit ist. Sie haben da alle so eine Angst davor. Meine Güte. Weißt du, was mich halt stört, ist, dass es im Moment so aussieht, wie wir verhandeln am Anfang irgendwie ein paar Wochen und dann schreiben wir sozusagen alle Eventualitäten möglichst maschinenlesbar hin. Und danach kann ein Computer das umsetzen. Da braucht man... So, dann frag ich mich, wieso zahlen wir den Leuten überhaupt noch Gehalt danach, wenn alles in dem Vertrag drin steht. Das kann ja auch irgendwie ein Hiwi ausführen.
Das hat genau dazu geführt, dass Wilders in Holland immer stärker wurde. Genau.
So was. Warum soll ich die denn wählen? Alles, was die machen, ist hier dem Vertrag folgen. Das kann auch irgendwie...
Genau.
Ein 1-Euro-Jobber.
Und das ist halt so ein... Na gut, also letztendlich war es halt so, dass die Koalitionsverträge dann halt immer noch hinreichend viel Spielraum boten, dass man da durchaus noch ein bisschen Politik machen konnte. Aber diese Tendenz ist halt immer genauer zu spezifizieren und vor allen Dingen nur zu sagen, wir wollen uns um dieses Themenfeld kümmern. Also was ja früher, was ja so ein Koalitionsvertrag stand drinne, ist ein wichtiges Themenfeld. Hier ist das Problem und wir werden im Laufe dieser Lästereperiode dafür eine Lösung finden. Ja, und man einigt sich vielleicht mal so grob auf die Richtung, auf die Maßnahme, die man halt in Erwägung zieht oder so. Also mal nur mal ansagen, da wollen wir hin, das ist auf der Agenda, wollen wir halt angehen so. Und dann hat man sich halt irgendwie später darauf geeinigt, halt wie man es jetzt konkret gemacht hat. Und das war zwar halt immer noch nicht toll, weil es halt dazu führte, dass die eigentlichen politischen Verhandlungen innerhalb der Koalition stattgefunden haben und halt nicht mehr im Parlament. Und halt dann mit Hilfe der Koalitionsdisziplin dann halt irgendwie im Zweifel durchgedrückt wurden. Aber es hat zumindest immerhin so was. Und eine Minderheitenregierung würde halt dazu führen, dass diese Verhandlungen halt im Parlament stattfinden müssen. Also dass halt also tatsächlich, wie ihr halt irgendwie seht...
Wo sie dokumentiert werden, wo der Bürger sie sehen kann. Oh mein Gott, das wäre ja furchtbar.
Naja, das Problem bei der Minderheitenregierung ist halt, dass in Deutschland ist halt niemand so etwas gewohnt. Also das Gefühl, was dabei entsteht, ist halt eins von Instabilität. Und nichts hasst der Deutsche mehr.
Das trennt sich halt so konservativ und progressiv. Der Konservative guckt sich das an und denkt, oh mein Gott, das sind unkartografierte Gewässer. Und der Progressive guckt sich das an und sagt, geil, das ist eine Gelegenheit, wir können das jetzt endlich besser machen.
Es gibt mal Gestaltungsspielraum.
Ja, aber das ist doch aber auch genau, was der Bürger eigentlich gerne haben möchte. Das Gefühl, also ich versuch's mal ganz plump zu sagen, regiert zu werden und nicht nur administriert. Also mir geht es jedenfalls so. Ich frage mich, warum soll ich denn irgendeinen von denen wählen, wenn alles, was die im Grunde machen, keinen Gestaltungsspielraum mehr hat. Und es geht ja sogar noch weiter, dass im Grunde schon Verpflichtungen der EU gegenüber und über irgendwelche anderen Verträge auch dazu führen, dass innerhalb von dem Budget überhaupt nur noch so 10 Prozent oder so Spielraum sind. Und Spielraum jetzt auch, also über das man überhaupt noch verhandeln kann.
Was sozusagen der Gestaltungsspielraum ist.
Ja. Und da frage ich mich dann ja, eigentlich kann man das auch ein Schelzgut machen lassen.
So ein Smart Contract in der Blockchain.
Ja, ich verkleif mir seit einer Stunde diesen blöden Spruch. In der Tat, das ist im Grunde sehe ich Ethereum und denke mir, da geht die Politik hin. Die einigen sich am Anfang auf irgendein Scheiß Smart Contract. Und dann wird das halt ausgeführt von irgendeinem Computer, dem alle vertrauen.
Dem sie ihre Wurz übertragen im Parlament.
Ja, das ist doch eine Dystopie. Da wollen wir doch nicht hin. Und alle arbeiten aber daran, dass es dahin geht, oder?
Na gut, solange das Ethereum ist, mach ich mir jetzt keine Gedanken, weil dann haben wir wieder mal ein bisschen politisch.
Haben wir endlich wieder als Hacker, haben wir wieder Gestaltungspiel.
Genau, da ist der Gestaltungspiel auch wieder vorhanden. Aber...
Tja, aber also die SPD, ich weiß nicht. Ich mein, ich bin ja immer, ich mag ja so Theorien lieber, wo jemand so schlau ist, dass es nicht, dass mir das nicht direkt eingefallen ist, ist mir lieber, als dass jemand so doof ist, dass ich das nicht in der Wege gezogen hätte. Insofern finde ich die Idee, dass die CDU, dass die SPD sich hier vielleicht schlau anstellt, finde ich ja ganz attraktiv eigentlich. Und es wäre mir auch sehr recht, wenn dieses Umfallen endlich mal aufhört. Ja, im Moment ist es halt so, dass die am Anfang ihrer Legislaturperiode den Gestaltungsspielraum im Grunde komplett aus der Hand geben und dann den Rest der Legislaturperiode damit füllen, so zu tun, als könnten sie jetzt hier noch was verhandeln. Und dann ja, das geht aber jetzt nicht. Und dann denke ich mir, also ich will doch keine Politiker, um mir dann sagen zu lassen, das geht alles nicht. Ja, ich möchte gern Politiker wählen, die sagen, das geht.
Ja, beziehungsweise finden wir eine Lösung.
Ja, oder wir haben zumindest, wenn sie schon keine Lösung finden, dann möchte ich wenigstens irgendwie ordentlich belogen werden. Ja, dann sollte es wenigstens so aussehen, als hätten sie es versucht.
Zumindest der Unterhaltungsfaktor soll das ärgern.
Mich wässte so, wenn dieses Gefühl, dass die mich so wenig ernst nehmen, dass sie mich nicht mal ordentlich belügen. Also weißt du das? Weißt du da, wofür steile ich eigentlich meine Steuern? Ja, also jetzt haben wir hier einen Übergang. Der ist so ein bisschen schwierig, was wir bei den hinkriegen.
Wie soll er denn jetzt gerade?
Wir haben jetzt den Übergang Österreich.
Naja, Österreich.
Und den Innenminister.
Den österreichischen Innenminister. Genau, erzähl mal was für diesen österreichischen Innenminister.
Ja, also ich hab ja, war einigermaßen entsetzt über die österreichische Regierung, die jetzt gerade frisch, der Kanzler wurde frisch eingeschworen. Das ist so ein 31-jähriger, ich will mal sagen Schnösel. Der wirkt wie so ein Typ aus einer Studentenvereinigung. Also rein äußerlich jetzt und von seinem Sogehabe. Der ist so so ein Typ, der die Talkshows irgendwie durchtingelt hat und hat dann da so knackige Statements rausgehauen. Ich würde mal sagen, in Deutschland von der Figur her höchstens mit dem Lindner vergleichbar.
Ja, so ein bisschen Gutenberg.
Ja, aber der ist ja nicht mehr. Aber ja, du hast echt, also stimmt, so eine Mischung aus Gutenberg und Lindner. So ein junger Schnösel, der irgendwie, der ist ja 31. Ich meine, das ist wahrscheinlich auch eine Sache, die mit dem Alter zu tun hat, dass man immer Leuten, die jünger sind, erst mal nichts zutraut und Leuten, die älter sind, da, denen gibt man so Benefit of the doubt. Ja, es kann sein, dass der was weiß und so. Aber ich meine, in den meisten Fällen ist es ja nicht so. Aber was sind ein 31-Jähriger, der sich aber geriert, wie so ein Aristokrat, der irgendwie weiß, wo es langgeht und der kann überhaupt nicht wissen, wo es langgeht. Aber er ist halt die Hoffnung der Partei, weil die anderen so abgesattelt sind.
Also sein großer Vorteil ist, dadurch, dass er so jung ist, hat er halt noch weniger Leichen im Keller. Das ist halt sozusagen der...
Aber er ist halt nicht befördert worden, weil er gut war, sondern weil die anderen alle...
Der Populist ist ja schon echt gut.
Ja, also ich will nicht sagen, dass er kein guter Populist ist, aber die anderen sind alle abgetreten wegen irgendwelcher...
Skandale. Ja, wegen Skandalen. Also ich meine, das waren halt einfach echt die Leichten im Keller.
Das ist einfach wirklich...
Ja, also der ist halt der sozusagen.
Der ist wie eine FDP, ist der Überbleibende. Er ist wie der Lindner.
Nein, nicht nur Dütte, sondern er hat auch schon was für getan, dass er da hinkommt. Und mein letztes Ernst, hat er die... Hat er die bei seiner Partei ja erpresst, ja?
Also ich will das nicht so darstellen, als wenn der doof ist. Aber er ist halt so ein...
Als Politiker ist der schon...
Also der ist halt so ein Schnöseltyp, der bei mir erst mal so krasse, krasse, irgendwie negative Reaktionen ausgelöst hat, als ich den zum ersten Mal gesehen hab.
Ich meine, ist halt so dieses...
Ich dachte so, was ist das denn für ein Typ, ja? Und der ist jetzt Kanzler. Und da dachte ich mir, na gut, okay, also der ist Kanzler. Mit wem denn? In der Koalition, mit der FPÖ. Und die FPÖ, das ist so die AfD Österreichs. Weiß nicht, ob das jetzt unfair ist. Die Haider-Partei.
Nicht sehr.
Ich weiß nicht, für wen es unfair ist. Also das ist halt, das und das sind völlig undiskutabel. Und während ich mich aufrege, hab ich dann mal ein bisschen Revue passieren lassen. Und das ist also, es gab ja diese Bundespräsidentenwahl vor einer Weile in Österreich, wo der eine Kandidat von den Grünen war, was ja auch tief blicken lässt. Keiner der Volksparteien hat es geschafft, einen Kandidaten hinzustellen, der diskutabel gewesen wäre. Und dann haben sie sich auf den Grünen geeinigt. Und der andere war von der FPÖ. Und es sah bis zuletzt so aus, als wenn die FPÖ das gewinnt, gegen alle anderen zusammen. Und dementsprechend muss man jetzt auch diese Koalition sehen. Die Österreicher sind sozusagen froh, dass die FPÖ der Junior-Partner ist. Aber es ist halt kein schwacher Junior-Partner, sondern die haben gerade sich sozusagen die komplette Exekutive geangelt. Die haben sowohl das Verteidigungsministerium als auch das Innenministerium. Und der Innenminister ist der Typ, der dem Heider die Reden geschrieben hat. Das ist so der Propaganda-Beauftragte der FPÖ gewesen, der hat so die ganzen furchtbaren Slogans für die Wahlplakate gemacht und so. Und ich dachte, naja, wie schlimm kann es sein? Ich meine, das betrifft mich ja ja alles nicht, deswegen guck ich da selten hin. Aber das sind dann so Sachen wie Daham, also Daheim statt Islam.
Das sind so Sprüche von dem Innenminister.
Das sind so Sprüche, die der zu verantworten hat. Und ich so, ach du meine Güte, und der ist jetzt Innenminister und der weiß, da hab ich dann echt eine Weile überlegt, ist das jetzt eigentlich schlimmer als bei uns? Oder ist das nicht besser? Sollte man nicht sozusagen froh sein, wenn so ein Heißluftgebläse-Innenminister ist, ist es irgendwie besser, als wenn es so ein geschulter Operative ist, der irgendwie genau weiß, wir machen hier, wir fordern mehr. Ich bin mir nicht sicher, du hast da eine Meinung zusammengestellt. Du hast lieber jemanden wie Chili, der sich auskennt.
Dann lieber so jemand wie Demisier oder so, der zumindest nicht inkompliziert ist. Der zumindest, würde ich mal sagen, intellektuell satisfaktionsfähig ist und in der Lage ist, das Management von diesen Behörden, selbst wenn ich mit seinen politischen Zielen nicht übereinstimme, zumindest in halbwegs professioneller Art und Weise hinzubekommen.
Na, aber die hat auch so ein paar Dinge rausgehauen in der Zeit.
Demisier ist jetzt halt so an so einem Punkt, wo der halt immer weiter nach rechts abdriftet und immer krasser wird.
Aber das kommt auch mit dem Amt, oder?
Ich glaube, das kommt aber auch mit dem Amt.
Haben wir schon mal einen Innenminister erlebt, der das nicht gemacht hat? Ich wüsste nämlich nicht.
Ja, schon wenn, dann eine Weile her.
Also aber echt lange her dann.
Aber die, also ich glaube, dass die also zum einen kommt mit dem Amt klar, weil natürlich immer die Forderung, dass ich jetzt Behörden zu vertreten hast. Aber jetzt ist natürlich auch klar, dass die CDU halt Angst hat davor, dass die AfD ihn halt noch weiter halt von ihnen wieder abgräbt. Und das zu verhindern, ist natürlich auch Aufgabe von Demisir. Und deswegen stellt er sich jetzt halt hin mit irgendwie Forderungen, wie halt irgendwie er gerne physische Backdoors in Autos und Alarmanlagen. Also die Hersteller verpflichten, da irgendwie Hintertüren einzubauen, was halt die erste Herstellerverpflichtung zu Hintertüren überhaupt wäre. Und das ist eigentlich ganz interessant, weil dieses, also was da kam halt von dem Rechercheverbund, klang ja so, als wurde auch Hintertüren halt irgendwie an möglichen Digitalgeräten fordern. Das war aber gar nicht ursprünglich die Intention dieses Papiers, sondern was die halt wollten, ist also Hintertüren, z.B. Herstellerkooperationsverpflichtungen bei Auto-Alarm-Anlagen und Gebäude-Alarm-Anlagen, also bei Dingen, die halt auf Dinge aufpassen. Und da kommt man natürlich in eine sehr interessante Fragestellung rein, nämlich wem vertraut man denn noch, wenn man sich jetzt eine Alarmanlage kauft, so irgendwie, woher weiß ich denn, dass die mir halt im Zweifel halt auch gegen die Polizei hilft oder habe ich gar kein Recht mehr dazu, dass meine Alarmanlage mir gegen die Polizei hilft?
Ich fand das auch sehr interessant, aber aus einer anderen Perspektive, weil ich habe so ein, also ich will nicht sagen, von langer Hand geplant, aber es wirkt fast als wäre das aus einem Guss, dass du erst Fake News machst, um die Medien irgendwie zu diskreditieren und dann hängst du dich an die Rhetorik gegen die Wirtschaftskrise und was weiß ich, die Industrie, den kann man nicht trauen. Und dann kommt sozusagen als letzter Ordnungsfaktor kommt die Regierung und sagt, hör mal, den Firmen traut ihr doch eh nicht, dann wollen wir die jetzt mal regulieren. Ja, so das schwingt so ein bisschen mit. Also, pass auf, wir als Polizei, wir sind die Letzten, denen man hier noch vertrauen kann und wenn wir dahinter Türen einbauen, diese ganze Rhetorik gegen Facebook, der ich mich zwar inhaltlich gerne anschließe, hat aber zu so einer Atmosphäre geführt, wie die wollen euch eh alle verarschen. Und zwar nicht nur Facebook, sondern auch so die Handy-Anbieter, Google natürlich sowieso. Gegen Apple war die Rhetorik jetzt nicht so doll, weil die auch inhaltlich nicht so viel Angriffsfläche an der Stelle.
Außer bei ihren Steuern.
Ja, aber das ist doch aber im Grunde derselbe Vektor, oder? Dass du sagst, die sind nicht vertrauenswürdig, die bescheißen uns alle. Und dann ist es nämlich viel einfacher zu argumentieren, warum wir den jetzt in Hintertüren reindrücken, wenn das eh alles Verbrecher sind.
Komme ich jetzt so mit der Logik nicht so ganz mit?
Nee, nicht Logik, sondern so gefühlsmäßig. Wer würde denn eine Firma verteidigen, von der wir das letzte halbe Jahr gelesen haben?
Du meinst sowas wie die Autohersteller?
Nee, ich mein jetzt sowas wie Google, Facebook.
Aber in dem Fall sind es halt die Autohersteller.
Ja, natürlich auch. Also jetzt nicht die, ich meine jetzt nicht so Gebäude-Alarmanlagen. Aber so hat auch niemand dieses Papier verstanden, wenn du mal guckst.
Ja, aber es ging halt zum Beispiel darum, dass irgendwie Autos halt Bescheid sagen, wenn sie halt verwanzt werden.
Das kann aber auch ein Testballon sein, dass du irgendwie sagst, es ging uns gar nicht um die Handys, aber eigentlich geht es uns doch um die Handys.
Also die Genese dieses Papiers war, der Gerüchtelage nach zu urteilen. Also ich weiß es halt nicht nicht zuverlässig, sondern ich hab halt nur so die Berliner Gerüchtelage so und die sagt halt, auf dieser Innenministerkonferenz haben die halt immer so Vorträge von halt aus ihren LKAs und vom BKA, wo die dann halt sagen, was so gerade ihre Probleme sind, was sie sich so wünschen. Und da hatten sie dann halt wohl Probleme mit insbesondere Auto-Alarmanlagen und Gebäude-Alarmanlagen und Zutrittssystemen, die sie halt nicht überwinden konnten, weswegen sie halt irgendwie Sachen nicht verwanzen konnten. Also halt irgendwie so in gut und daraus folgt halt schon, wenn sie eine Genehmigung für Verwanzen kommen.
Moment, Moment. Seit wann verwanzt man denn irgendwelche Großkonzerne?
Es geht ja nicht um Großkonzerne, es geht um Alarmanlagen. Kannst du ja mal die kaufen.
Nein, aber das sind doch wohl die Alarmanlagen, die...
Nein, nein. Da ging es um normal Alarmanlagen.
Ist nicht dein Ernst, oder? Das ist so das Privatapartment vom Drogendealer. Ist mit Alarmanlagen ernsthaft? Da scheitern die an den Alarmanlagen?
Zumindest hatten sie da wohl...
Das darf ja wohl nicht wahr sein....
so Probleme, ja.
Wie inkompetent sind die denn?
Insbesondere ging es darum, dass die halt silent SMSen oder WhatsApp-Messages schicken und so Sachen. Und dass sie dann halt nicht die Alarmanlage losgeht, sondern es einfach nur Bescheid sagt, wenn die versucht haben, das Auto zum Beispiel zu verwandeln, oder die Hütte.
Warte mal, das flasht mich ja jetzt. Das kann doch nicht wahr sein, dass die an so einer Aldi-Alarmanlage scheitern.
Ich weiß jetzt nicht, ob es eine Aldi-Alarmanlage war. Es gibt da auch schon noch höherwertige Produkte.
Scheiße, ich hätte doch Popcorn mitbringen sollen. Verdammt.
Also wie gesagt, auch eine Aldi-Alarmanlage war. Weiß ich nicht, aber die Gerüchtelage ist halt, dass es halt irgendwie eine, also dass halt Mierefälle waren, dass sie halt sozusagen so einen Pattern ausgemacht haben und dann eine Lösung für suchten. Und dann entstand daraus dieses Paper, dass sie gesagt haben, so ja, wir hätten gerne wie eine Herstellerkooperationsverpflichtung. Also dass der Hersteller verpflichtet ist, irgendwie auf ein Begehren eines Strafeformsorgans, was halt irgendwie mit einer STPO-Anfrage kommt und sagt, wir hätten hier gerne mal denen dann halt zu helfen, sprich also eine Hintertür einzubauen. Und diese Paper eskalierte dann offensichtlich so ein bisschen hin zu einer technisch generischeren Formulierung. Also das ist halt irgendwie um eine Verpflichtung von Herstellern zum Kooperieren ging bei dem Überwinden von Schutzsystemen oder so ähnlich. Also so eine generische Formulierung so. Und dann kam mit irgendwie einen Journalisten dieses Paper und dann eskalierte die Sache natürlich in der Presse und dann hatten sie halt so ein Problem und haben auch so rumdementiert gesagt, so war es ja gar nicht gemeint und so. Aber jedenfalls ist die ganze Sache halt so ein bisschen irgendwie unprofessionell entlitten halt. Das war halt so der Hintergrund davon. Aber es passte halt eben ins Bild, wenn du jetzt halt irgendwie anguckst, so was du mir sie ja sonst noch so absieht, der zum Beispiel mit der Videoüberwachung und Gesichtserkennung.
Ja und also ich finde ja wir erleben seit ungefähr, ich weiß nicht, anderthalb Jahren so einen Deutungshoheitkrieg zwischen den Techfirmen und den Regierungen. Ja, dass die Regierung fordern irgendwelche Kryptohintertüren und die Techfirmen oder gerade Apple hat ja da irgendwie sich dann geweigert und Microsoft, also es gibt so einen Krieg darum, wer schützt euch eigentlich vor wem, wer ist hier der Gute und wer ist der Böse zwischen den Tech-Anbietern und den Regierungen. Und eigentlich hauptsächlich in den USA, aber das ist natürlich eine Frage, die sich auch bei uns stellt. Wenn jetzt, sagen wir mal, die Polizei gerne eine Hintertür in irgendeinem Messenger haben möchte, ist es dann, wer schützt uns hier vor wem? Sind die Polizei automatisch die Guten oder ist das legitim oder ist es sogar vielleicht deren Pflicht, von dem Messenger-Anbieter dann zu sagen, wir machen das nicht einfach auf Zuruf. Also die Frage, wer hier eigentlich den Bürger vor wem schützt, ist im Moment offen, finde ich. Und da, in dem Kontext, ging es mir auch gar nicht so um die konkreten Forderungen in diesem Papier, sondern das ist einfach ein weiteres Scharmützel auf dem Gebiet. Es wirkt so ein bisschen wie so ein, ich sag mal, so ein Indiana-Jones-Film, wo die irgendwie so eine Wand abtapfen, um zu sehen, wo ist hier die Schwachstelle, ja? Was sie, so wir haben angefangen mit den Handys und dann haben wir so ISPs, haben irgendwie, kriegen Polizeibriefe und dann hieß es Hintertüren irgendwie, wir müssen ins Routing eingreifen und dann Telefonnetz wird sowieso und wanzen. Also aber sie klopfen im Grunde überall und gucken, wo ist eine Schwachstelle? Wo kommen wir rein? Dann hieß es die Autos. Die USA sind da ja auch vorne. Da gibt es schon im Gesetz festgeschrieben, irgendwie Peilsender im Auto, dass die Autos über die erste Hilfesysteme irgendwie ordbar sein müssen und dass sie aus der Ferne von einem sie verfolgenden Polizeiwagen aus irgendwie remote abgeschaltet werden können und so. Also das ist, glaube ich, ein internationaler Krieg gerade. Wer hier soll uns die Privatwirtschaft vor der Polizei schützen oder nicht? Und die die Fragestellung an sich wäre ja, ich sag mal, in den 70ern oder so völlig absurd gewesen. Oder?
Also ich weiß nicht, ob sie völlig absurd gewesen wäre, weil zu Zeiten der Stammheim und so, okay.
Ja, zu Zeiten der RAF wäre es also, glaube ich, Aber es ist schon eigentlich absurd, dass wir überhaupt darüber reden, ob uns jemand vor den Übergriffen der Polizei schützen muss. Das sagt eigentlich schon so viel über den Zustand der Gesellschaft aus, dass man ernsthaft über diese Frage nachdenkt. Und dass Google zum Beispiel diese Transparenz irgendwie offensive fährt für Seiten, die ihnen mit von irgendwelchen Regierungen abgeschossen werden.
Also ich glaube, dass dieses Problem mit dem, wie sich diese Tech-Konzerne oder auch normale Firmen gegenüber, so Begehren von so Regierungen stellen, hat eine Menge damit zu tun, dass es jetzt halt offen ist. Also früher funktionierte sowas, heute noch funktioniert sowas ganz viel informer. Also zum Beispiel, nehmen wir mal, hast du einen Türschlosshersteller, ja? Die haben...
Oh, jetzt kommen hier die guten Stomps.
Die haben da irgendwie so informelle Beziehungen. Also das halt dann funktioniert dann halt so, dass halt, wenn halt irgendwie die Polizei, nehmen wir mal das BKA, will halt irgendwo eine Wand zu unterbringen, dann haben sie halt da halt irgendwie ihre Leute, die halt die Schlötter picken. Teilweise sind es halt irgendwie freie Dienstleister, die sie da halt irgendwie mitbringen. Wenn sie halt irgendwie offen reingehen, dann holen sie halt sich ein Schlüsselunternehmen, die Tür aufzumachen. Oder wenn sie halt verdeckt reingehen, dann haben sie halt Leute, die das können. So und ob sie jetzt Beamte sind oder wie die nur angezogen werden, hängt halt vom Fall ab. So und das aber ist und die Leute wiederum haben natürlich dann beziehungsweise Schlosshersteller, die irgendwie wissen, welche Tools funktionieren. Oder wenn sie zum Beispiel eine Seriennummer haben von dem Schlüssel, weil sie den mal fotografiert haben, irgendwo am Schlüsselbund von dem Verdächtigen, dann können sie halt irgendwie damit zum Hersteller gehen und dann gibt es halt so Unterhand, so Kooperationen mit irgendwie, wir machen nochmal einen Schlüssel dafür, die Nummer. So oder zum Beispiel halt oder Tresore. Es ist halt irgendwie auch so, da gibt es halt irgendwie dann so Bohrschablonen, die halt irgendwie von den Tresorherstellern an die Firmen, die halt professionell Tresore aufmachen, die verkauft werden, sind halt so große Papierschablone, die klebst du halt auf die vorne, auf das Ding rauf und dann machst du da halt irgendwie ein Loch rein und dann hakelst du den Tresor auf. So und dann treibst du da wieder einen Wolframmstift rein, polierst du ihn und lackierst ihn, dann siehst du das halt auch nicht mehr. So also so eine Sachen. Diese also diese informellen Höfen, die gibt es halt schon immer. Und so funktioniert das halt ja auch natürlich bei vielen Start-ups und bei bei Internetfirmen. Wenn da halt die Polizei kam, sagte hier, wir sind hier gerade an diesem Kindersternring dran und bräuchten eure Hilfe. Gibt es nur sehr, sehr wenige Firmen, die dann halt gesagt haben nee, na oder kommt mal wieder mit möglichst Beschluss. Sondern die meisten haben gesagt, so naja gut klar, stadsbürgerliche Pflicht und so und die wollen ja auch die Bösen kriegen. Und das Problem, was die jetzt halt haben, ist halt, dass halt die Vielzahl der Systeme so groß geworden ist und dass halt die die Mengen der Firmen, mit der sie auf diese Art und Weise interagieren müssen, so groß geworden ist, dass dieser informelle Weg einfach schlicht nicht mehr funktioniert, weil vielleicht hat ihr Drogendealer halt irgendwie einen Schloss von einem Start-up irgendwie an seiner Hütte dran, von dem sie noch nie gehört haben, wo sie erstmal nachgucken müssen, wo die sitzen. Oder wenn halt irgendwie Auto-Alarmanlagen nach ist, Kitsou mit irgendwie noch einem Krypto-Messenger ran getackert, kannst du ja mittlerweile irgendwie ins Affair machen. Also ist ja irgendwie kein Problem. Sonst liest du ja halt irgendwie da eine gepatchte Signal-App irgendwie auf deinem android-boardcomputer und dann kannst du dir halt irgendwie Nachrichten schicken, nachdem es dir im Auto geht. So ist ja im Rahmen der technischen Möglichkeiten alles heutzutage kein Problem mehr. Und daraus resultiert halt dieses Begehren, halt zu sagen, wir brauchen halt irgendwie irgendeine insozialisierte Kooperationsmöglichkeit. Aber wozu das natürlich dann führt, ist, dass es halt natürlich nicht wieder im Einzelfall und nur im besonders schweren Fall und so weiter angewendet wird, wenn so ein Ding einmal besteht, sondern halt dann normal regelmäßig. Und deshalb ist das tatsächlich ein großes Problem, weil die drei Fälle, wo sie den Leuten mal eine Wanze in die Hütte tun, so und weil ich meine, das hat ja sehr hohe Voraussetzungen.
Wissen wir das oder ist das eine Befürchtung?
Was?
Dass das automatisch irgendwie leichtfertig benutzt wird, wenn der Weg nicht mehr steinig ist.
Also gehen wir mal den hypothetischen Fall durch.
Also es gibt so Einzelfälle wie den Finanzbeamten, der erwischt wird, wie er bei seinen Nachbarn guckt.
Das sind keine Einzelfälle.
Ja, aber woher wissen wir das? Also es gibt, man weiß ja immer nur von so ein paar Fällen.
Genau.
Und dann hat man so geraune, das sind halt viele Fälle. Gibt es da belastbare Zahlen?
Also es gibt mal Leute, die mal versucht haben, zusammenzutragen, was es so an bekannten Fällen gibt, wo Leute halt vor Gericht verurteilt worden sind oder Strafe viele bekommen haben. Und das sind halt mehrere Dutzend pro Jahr. Also von irgendwelchen Beamten, die halt irgendwie ihre Einsichtsrechte missbrauchen. Und das ist halt nur eine Dunkelziffer. Also es ist halt nur die, die wussten halt, ob man zur Anzeige kam. Aber lass uns mal nicht da abgleiten, weil der Fall ist, den lass mal den mal rauslassen, weil der führt uns auf einen irren Weg. Interessanter ist halt der Fall, wenn diese Mitwirkungspflicht sich halt zum Beispiel auch auf die gesamte Software eines Autos erstrecken würde, wäre halt das Verwandten eines Autos oder das Benutzen des boardcomputers für einen Lauschangriff auf die Telefonate, die da geführt werden, über die Freisprecherrichtung im Auto, nur ein Software-Update. Das heißt, du hast halt quasi in einem Auto schon eine Situation, wie du sie erst in ein paar Jahren in einem Smart Home haben wirst, dass es also quasi einen Computer gibt, der die Herrschaft über alles, was in diesem Auto passiert hat, hat. Also von der Kontrolle über das Audiosystem in deinem Auto mit allen Mikrofonen bis hin tatsächlich zur Fahrkontrolle.
Na gut, aber ich will mal dagegen argumentieren, dass im Grunde du das auch ohne Kooperation der Hersteller machen kannst. Das dauert halt länger und kostet mehr. Aber es ist nicht so, dass es eine fundamentale Schranke gibt, solche Sachen zu machen, sondern das ist alles irgendwie Hardware und Software.
Natürlich, bloß in dem Anblick, wo sie halt eine Kooperationsverpflichtung reinschreiben würden, würde es halt trivial einfacher werden. Und wenn es trivial einfach ist, dann benutzen wir es massenweise. Haben wir bisher bei allen gesehen. Okay. Also der Punkt ist halt, nur wenn es halt tatsächlich irgendwie ein bisschen schwierig ist und also nicht einfach zu realisieren ist, gibt es irgendwie geartete natürliche Schranke. Und also gut, Wohnung verwandeln gibt es halt natürliche Schranke auch bedingt durch die richtigen Voraussetzungen. Aber Autos verwandeln zum Beispiel ist halt unter einem sehr, sehr viel niedrigeren, also brauchst du eine sehr, sehr viel niedrige Anforderung für. So und wenn das halt irgendwie einfach so standardmäßig geht, dann wird es halt eben doch benutzt werden.
Dieses greift mir grad so ein bisschen in der Argumentation rein, an der ich so seit einem halben Jahr ungefähr arbeite, hab dieses Jahr so ein paar Vorträge gehalten und da ging es eigentlich so um Softwareentwicklung und Fehltrends. Und eine der Sachen, die ich argumentiert habe, ist, dass wir immer versuchen, irgendwie Updates möglichst, also unsere Produktzyklen zu kürzen, damit wir sofort deployen können, eine neue Version. Und dass wir ein Updater haben, am besten, wenn das irgendwie ein Gerät im Feld ist, irgendwo over the air am besten. Und mein Argument oder meine Überlegung dazu ging bisher in die Richtung, dass wir dann die Schranke senken vor dem Release. Also es gibt keinen Anreiz mehr, das Release ordentlich zu machen, weil du ja patchen kannst. Du musst nur dafür sorgen, dass der Updater nicht betroffen ist, wenn da jemand ausfällt. Aber den Winkel, dass man mit diesem Trend, der ja wirklich branchenübergreifend ist, dass man alles immer sofort updaten, neu bauen kann, dass man damit eben auch so Polizeistaatgeschichten befördert, das finde ich eigentlich ziemlich belastend gerade, muss ich sagen. Das finde ich, so ein Winkel, den habe ich zumindest noch nicht angesprochen öffentlich. Aber wir schaufeln uns sozusagen unser eigenes Grab. Ja, wenn wir in unsere Software überall Update-Möglichkeiten einbauen, heißt es eben auch, dass die Polizei da updaten kann.
Wie gesagt, der wichtige Punkt dabei ist halt, dass wenn der Hersteller, also wenn es keine Kooperationspflicht des Herstellers gibt und der Update-Mechanismus hinreichend gesichert ist, dann besteht dieses Problem halt nicht in dem Augenblick, wo es halt eine Herstellerkooperationspflicht gibt, wird tatsächlich dieses Fundament irgendwie von moderner IT-Security, nämlich halt möglichst einfach Updateability angriffen.
Naja, also ich sag mal, nimm mal an, du versuchst es jetzt ordentlich abzusichern. Das läuft in der Praxis dann darauf hinaus, dass du Co-Signing hast auf deine Firmware-Updates und dass du irgendwie über SSL oder sowas deinen Update-Kanal machst. Das ist beides gesichert über einen privaten Schlüssel. Den könnte man auch mal beschlagnahmen, sag ich jetzt mal. Also wenn die Firma nicht kooperieren will und die Polizei sagt, es geht hier um Terroristen, dann gehen die da halt rein und nehmen den Schlüssel mit. Also das ist nicht so, dass eine Firma sich da wirklich wehren kann und wenn wir diesen Kanal einmal geschaffen haben, dass das Auto nicht mehr in die Werkstatt fahren muss, um ein Firmware-Update zu kriegen und irgendwie an ein Spezialgerät angeschlossen werden muss, sondern das im Feld geht, dann zerschießen wir uns eben die Vertrauenswürdigkeit unserer kompletten Infrastruktur. Nicht nur gegenüber der Polizei, sondern das kann dann auch irgendwie die NSA den Schlüssel mitnehmen.
Was sie eben auch schon getan hat.
Ja, haben sie ja gemacht. Und das ist ein sehr besorgniserregender Trend, dass wir uns eigentlich auf nichts mehr verlassen können. Und zwar in zweierlei Hinsicht, selbst wenn wir jetzt sowas hätten wie ein Korrektheitsbeweis, sorgen die Updates dafür, dass es seit dem Stand, mit dem wir den Beweis angefangen haben, inzwischen schon fünf Updates gibt wieder. Also die Software, das ist alles so in Bewegung, dass wir über die Systeme überhaupt keine Aussagen mehr treffen können.
Zumal halt einfach die Menge an Komponenten, die in so einem System steckt. Und also auch wenn man sich so eine typische Auto-Farmware, da steckt halt der Tonnenweise ums Haus Software drin.
Ja, aber das ist ja nicht nur eine Firmware, sondern du hast ein verteiltes System, du kannst die einzelnen Komponenten gar nicht mehr in Separationen betrachten, weil die überhaupt nur hochkommen, wenn fünf andere Komponenten auch da sind. Also ja, ich beobachte das mit großer Sorge. Ich habe vor ein paar Jahren mal geblockt, dass mein letztes Auto keine Elektronik drin hatte. Die Leute haben gedacht, das ist ein Witz. Inzwischen habe ich gar kein Auto mehr. Aber wenn man sich so ein modernes Auto anguckt, da wird einem ganz schlecht, finde ich.
Also tatsächlich ist es so, dass...
Hunderte an Mikrocontrollern, die über irgendwelche Netze miteinander reden.
Also wenn man halt so ein modernes Auto anguckt, ist die häufigste Ursache von Problemen sind Softwareprobleme und Sensorprobleme.
Ja, das ist nicht überraschend, weil immer mehr von der Komplexität eben in Software gemacht wird.
Beziehungsweise, die immer mehr Komplexitäten zugefügt wird in Software. Also die ist ja nicht so, dass Komplexität weggeht, sondern die kommt ja immer nur neu hinzu. Das Auto wird ja in keiner Stelle irgendwie einfacher, sondern es sind immer kompliziertere Lösungen, die dann halt irgendwie noch ein bisschen mehr Komfort oder Kostengewinn irgendwie dazu bringen.
Ich habe mich auch mal gefragt, wie viel länger so ein Elektroauto-Akku halten könnte, wenn du mal systematisch die ganzen Controller rausschmeißen würdest.
Also tatsächlich sind die Computing-Controller im Vergleich zu einer Sitzheizung oder einer normalen Aufwärtsung völlig irrelevant. Es ist tatsächlich so. Es gibt Tests zu Leuten, die Elektroautos testen, die gucken nach, was sind denn so noch die Verbraucher, die man rausschmeißen könnte. Der optionalste Verbraucher ist natürlich immer die Stereo-Anlage, weil die kannst du nun mit 50 Watt betreiben als mit 500 Watt.
Ja, war das gut.
Und 500 Watt ist halt schon...
Macht das jemand?
Na klar, wenn du so eine ordentliche fette Bassbox drin hast, dann wuppt die da ganz schön Strom raus. Und dann hast du halt die Heizung, sind halt so der allergrößte optionale Verbraucher und der ganze Schnick Schnack so Navigation und irgendwie Display und Schnickl-Düns im Vergleich zu dem, was halt irgendwie da an die Fahrleistung und die Heizung geht halt nicht mehr so viel. Aber die, ich glaube, dass es halt so ist, dass die generelle Zeit bis ein Auto moralisch verschlissen ist, also bis es sozusagen nicht mehr, also die Software nicht mehr funktioniert oder nicht mehr supported ist oder du halt keine Updates dafür mehr bekommst, was halt dazu führt, dass es eigentlich unverkauflich wird oder dass halt der sozusagen einfach nicht mehr benutzbar ist. Trotzdem ist wahrscheinlich mechanisch noch total okay, ist da über manchmal Sorgen. Weil gerade bei Elektroautos ist ja so, dass die Anzahl der mechanischen Teile sinkt ja dramatisch, also dass sie sehr viel weniger bewegte Teile und überhaupt viel weniger Teile.
Könnte also für ewig halten.
Genau. Und so ein Elektromotor, wenn du den schmierst, also wenn die Lager in Ordnung sind, dann geht halt auch nichts kaputt dran. Da kann also meine so eine Turbine in so einem Kraftwerk, was halt irgendwie so dieselbe Technologieklasse ist, die läuft für Jahrzehnte. Also das ist halt, wenn die halt ein bisschen gewartet wird. Und das ist halt so ein Ding, wo ich mir halt eher Sorgen drum mache, dass also die Langlebigkeit dieser energetisch relativ teuer herzustellenden Dinge, dass die halt leidet. Die Akkus haben halt keine Ahnung. Die halten halt irgendwas zwischen fünf und zehn Jahren oder so. Und dann müssen sie halt ausgetauscht werden. Die kann aber gut recycelt werden. Also es hat nicht so immer wieder rauszupolken und halt einen neuen Akku zu bauen, ist jetzt irgendwie kein Hexenwerk. Aber wenn der Rest halt so dermaßen Software kontrolliert ist, dann ist halt die Frage, wie lange kriegst du halt Updates? So viele gibt es ja jetzt Updates. Was sind irgendwie?
Das wäre ja eigentlich, finde ich, nicht schlecht. Aber es ist ja so, dass sich die Komponenten dann auch alle kurzlebig verhalten. Also theoretisch könnte man sich ja sowas vorstellen, wie ich sag jetzt mal, Boeing 747 ist seit irgendwie 1960 in Betrieb.
Also Flugzeuge halt, ja. Oder BN 52, seit 50 Jahren oder sowas.
Und wenn du sagst, sozusagen das Chassis ist immer dasselbe und die Computer sind alle dieselben Komponenten, und dann wäre das ja nicht schlecht, dann könntest du halt ewig deine Software updaten. Aber das machen die ja nicht. Und ich frage mich langsam, ob das eigentlich Absicht ist oder ob das irgendwie glückliche Fügung ist für die Autohersteller. Denn wir sehen bei so Spieleherstellern, sehen wir so einen Trend, dass du ein Spiel kaufst seit vielen Jahren jetzt, und du musst es erst mal mit dem Account verknüpfen, bevor du spielen kannst. Und dann ist es aber auch nicht mehr weiterverkaufbar. Ja, also und da sagen die Spielehersteller natürlich, das hätten sie nicht deswegen gemacht, aber das ist natürlich ein toller Seiteneffekt für die. Und ich frage mich, ob die Autohersteller jetzt auch auf so ein Ding auffahren und sagen, ja, also klar können sie das weiterverkaufen. Das funktioniert dann halt nicht mehr.
Na eigentlich können sie das nicht tun, weil der Wiederverkaufswert spielt halt bei einer Autoanschaffung schon für viele Leute eine große Rolle. Weil die Frage halt, wenn sie es halt nach fünf Jahren oder sechs Jahren verkaufen oder so, wie viel ist denn der Wertverlust? Ist halt für viele Leute schon ein essenzieller Bestandteil ihrer Kalkulation für das Auto.
Aber es reicht ja, wenn es sich obsolet anfühlt. Es muss ja nicht wirklich obsolet sein.
Also wenn die Software einen so großen Anteil ausmacht und nicht mehr updatebar ist. Und tatsächlich ist es häufig genug durchaus so, dass die Hardware einfach nicht mehr reicht. Also wir haben ja jetzt ja nur schon so ein paar Generationen von so wie Onboard Computing in Autos, also zum Beispiel so Navigationssystemen und so. Und da ist es halt einfach so, dass da reicht dann halt der Prozesshand der Speicher nicht mehr aus für die modernen Systeme. Weil sich niemand halt dann die Mühe macht, das halt so weit runter zu optimieren, weil die moderne Hardware ist halt so viel billiger. Und da hatten die Japaner halt irgendwann mal angefangen zu sagen, so wir machen mal so ein Standardgefäßsystem. Also halt so ein Slot-in-Computer, den du halt einfach alle paar Jahre einfach tauschen kannst gegen das nächste dickere Gerät. Ist nicht so richtig weit gekommen, was bisher nicht Standard geworden ist. Da brauchst du definitiv einen regulatorischen Eingriff. Also da brauchst du eine...
Intel macht sowas gerade. Die haben, es ist bisher so ein Marketing-Gimmick, aber die verkaufen so einen Checkkarten-Computer. Und der läuft, wenn du ihn in so einen Chassis einbaust, was so Formfaktor, weiß nicht, ein altes CD-ROM-Laufwerk ist, dafür slottest du halt deine Karte rein, aber der gesamte Rechner ist auf der Karte drauf. Ja, das Hauptproblem ist dann irgendwie Hitzeentwicklung und so. Aber theoretisch...
Könnte man sowas bauen, ja klar.
Aber dazu brauchst du halt keine...
Dazu brauchst du halt einen regulatorischen Eingriff, also eine Stabilisierung, dass man sagt, okay, ist halt wie ein Autoradio, gibt's halt irgendwie drei Formfaktoren und die müssen halt supported sein und...
Ja, aber komm, das funktioniert doch nicht. Guck dir doch nur mal an, dieses Debakel mit den Mini-USB-Steckern, was ja, bevor sie es gemacht haben, so aussah, als würde es uns alle retten von dem, dem Ladegerät, von der Ladegeräthölle, dass irgendwie es gab...
Ist doch aber getan.
Na, es gibt jetzt inzwischen haben wir USB-C und dann passt es schon wieder nicht mehr.
Ja, aber ich meine...
Und jetzt haben wir keinen Mikrofon-Slot mehr, also fuck you, Apple.
Na gut, also ich meine, Apple war ja schon immer draußen dabei, aber die... Aber ehrlich gesagt, fand ich also tatsächlich diese Regulierung, dass die Chinesen gesagt haben, muss halt irgendwie entweder Mini- oder Mikro-USB sein.
Ja, fand ich auch total super, aber es hat schon lange gehalten.
Tatsächlich hat die Anzahl der Ladegeräte, die ich so betreiben muss, drastisch reduziert.
Ja, ja, bei mir auch, aber...
Also ich finde, dass man da ein bisschen...
Ist schon wieder vorbei.
Dass man da so ein bisschen Innovationen drin hat, finde ich jetzt nicht tragisch.
Also wenn du dir mal die CT-Artikel über die USB-Lade-Protokoll-Aushandel-Dinger da durchliegst, dann wirst du das auch nicht einsetzen. Also der Trend ist ja, dass man über so ein Kabel vorher aushandelt beim Reinstecken.
Wie viel Strom da kommt.
Wie viel Strom da kommt. Und da gibt es halt so Multi-Layer. Und die Industrie-Selbstregulierung hat natürlich auf ganzer Strecke versagt. Das heißt, irgendwie du kannst halt ein Ladegerät kaufen, was dann lädt, aber nur mit irgendwie zwei Ampere. Also es gibt jetzt halt verschiedene Ladegeräte-Klassen, die auf dem Papier irgendwie dieselben Standards sprechen, aber dann halt doch nicht.
Also meine USB-C war mir ehrlich gesagt noch ein bisschen zu early adopter, als dass ich das irgendwie schon in mein Alter integrieren wollte.
Ja, ich habe sozusagen eins der ersten Geräte davon gekriegt, als ich mir so ein Pixelbook ließen, die damals noch Chromebook Pixel geholt habe. Die gab es hier gar nicht auf dem Markt, habe ich mir geholt, weil ich gerade drüben in Amerika war. Und der hat halt nur USB-C und einen USB-A-A-Slot für eine Maus.
So ein Apple-Gerät quasi.
Ist sozusagen ein Apple-Gerät, aber halt von Google. Und da, also ich fand das total affig, aber inzwischen, also es ist eigentlich, eigentlich ist es nett, wenn es vernünftig von der Umsetzung her funktionieren würde.
Oacid-Libre von Stockholm Syndrome.
Nein, also ich benutze das ganz selten. Aber das Konzept finde ich eigentlich gut, aber es funktioniert halt in der Praxis nicht. Aber so die Idee mal zu standardisieren, ist ja nett. Nur das ist jetzt der wievielte Standardisierungsversuch, den ich sehe.
Der dritte.
Ja, und also ich meine, wenn du Firewire mitzählst.
Ja, Firewire war kein Ladestandard.
Nein, aber so um um deine Peripherie anzuschließen.
Ja gut, da gab es Dutzende davor. Also Priviereanschluss, da brauchen wir nicht mehr.
Seit Jahren werden wir hier und das ist aber der letzte, den ihr brauchen werdet, weil der kann alles. Und dann so zehn Minuten später nicht mal, hier bei bei HDMI und so können die sich einigen. Das ist auch irgendwie, sobald du ein Gerät kaufst, ne jetzt gibt es 1.4a und jetzt gibt es aber 2.0. Und jetzt gibt es aber 2.1. Leute, was soll denn das?
Das ist aber der technische Fortschritt.
Nein, das ist Verarschung, Kundenverarschung. Aber egal, wir kommen hier gerade so ein bisschen vom Thema ab. Eigentlich wollten wir noch über, eigentlich waren wir dahin, dass da ist. Es gab ja gerade noch diese Sachsen-Geschichte. Ich weiß nicht, was du da jetzt erzählen wolltest. Also die haben so ein Panzer gekauft, so ein Truppentransporter. Also offensichtlich Militärartwehr.
Von Reingemetall.
Ja, da bleiben auch keine Fragen offen. Das ist halt so ein Militärbedarf. Und das Ding sieht schon aus wie Krisengebiet, Kriegsgebiet. Hält irgendwie Bombardierung aus, so von der Optik her. Und das kam dann in der Presse hoch, weil da so ein Zierradbestickung auf den Sitzen ist.
Genau.
Die so ein bisschen aussah, wie irgendwie so.
Also die haben da, die Beschriftung ist ja Sondereinsatzkommando Sachsen.
Und das sah aus wie so ein Orden aus dem Dritten Reich von der Optik.
Also die von der Anmutung der Optik halt eher so ein, naja, mindestens Wehrmacht wahrscheinlich, aber eher so Nazi-Dingens. Und wie war das jetzt? Du hast da mit den Frakturnauts in deinem Block gekloppt?
Also die Schrift ist halt Fraktur. Das sind diese alten, was viele Leute mit dem Dritten Reich assoziieren. Dabei ist es eigentlich eine Sache, die das Dritte Reich abschaffen wollte. Und ich hab da so ein...
Liegt das vielleicht an den Games, weil da die ganzen...
Ja, ja, natürlich. Das sind die ganzen ignoranten Amis, die glauben, das ist halt Nazi. Ja, so. Aber der Punkt ist, Fraktur hat halt so ein, hat zwei S. Zwei Zeichen für das kleine S. Das eine sieht aus wie so ein F ohne, ohne Querstrich, ist halt so das lange S. Ja, und das andere ist so wie unser heutiges S im Grunde. So, und da gibt es halt Regeln dafür, dass du am, am, am silben Übergang so oder beim, beim Wortende nimmst du halt das, das reguläre S, das wir heute überall benutzen, aber mitten im Wort. Also wenn du sowas hast wie, was weiß ich, Blasen oder so oder in diesem Fall Einsatzkommando. Ja, das ist das S bei Einsatzkommando wäre halt so ein Binnen-S und da hätte man eigentlich zu lange S genommen. Also sie haben sozusagen die, die, die Schrift sieht aus, wie man das aus so Neonazi-Szenen so, so kennt, dass die benutzen halt diese Schrift, weil sie glauben, es sei irgendwie eine Nazischriftart, was es nicht ist. Also das ist schon der, der Lacher ist. Es gibt da so ein Goebbels, Goebbels Aussage, als sie im zweiten Weltkrieg versucht haben, die Schrift komplett loszuwerden, wo sie das als als Judenschrift bezeichnet haben, um es loszuwerden. Ja. Und die, die Nazis wollten nämlich eigentlich Antiqua- schriften haben, wie wir sie heute auch benutzen.
Er ist halt modern.
Ja, war modern, haben alle anderen auch gemacht. Aber jedenfalls, das heißt sozusagen die, die falsche Schriftart und das falsche S. Und dann hat mir noch jemand so einen Link geschickt zu dem Logo vom Sonder-Einsatzkommando von Sachsen. Das sieht aus, als wenn es das falsche Logo ist. Aber es ist nicht so richtig gut erkennbar. Und es kann auch sein, dass diese Webseite einfach eine alte Version von Logo hat. Also das glaub ich jetzt nicht, dass die so doof sind, das falsche Logo. Das wird doch ungetauscht, oder? Also das kaufen, das nehmen die doch dann nicht ab.
Na also ich weiß nicht, dass ich glaube so eine Detail-Sti halt irgendwie bei so Hardware.
Du kaufst doch nicht irgendwie einen Wasserwerfer 10.000 und da ist dann die falsche Schrift drauf.
Ja, aber das war innen.
Naja, egal. Aber jedenfalls der eigentliche Lacher an dieser ganzen Geschichte war, dass sie einen Tarnmodus haben.
In diesem Auto?
In dem Artikel bezeichnet haben als Undercover-Modus. Und ich dachte, das ist der Posteljungen. Denn was sie damit meinen, ist, dass draußen der Schriftzug Polizei auf so einem Ding ist, was man in der Mitte klappen kann. Das heißt, du hast also diesen Panzer...
In Polizei Blau?
In Polizei Blau, wo du das Polizeiaufschrift runterklappst und dann ist der getarnt. So, das merken die nicht, dass das hier Polizei ist. So ein Panzer rollt durch die Innenstadt, nimmt einen Walz, drei Passanten, platt auf den Weg, weißt du so? Also der Ding ist nicht subtil. Das als Undercover-Modus, wo ich sagte, Leute, wirklich? Aber es war, glaub ich, ernst gemeint. Also ich...
Naja, es wird...
So ein bisschen sprachlos.
Ich bin unter diesem Aspekt relativ gespannt, wie der Kongress in Sachsen so laufen wird.
Ich bin mir sicher, alles wird gut.
Wir gehen mal davon aus, dass alles gut wird.
Das soll man sonst tun. So, also eigentlich der Übergang Maschinenlearning hätte besser gepasst nach den Alarmanlagen, finde ich.
Nee, wir können jetzt noch die Sache mit der Gesichtserkennung, kunt ihr mir nicht nennen, Minister.
Ach so, meinst du den...
Der übernomm ich aufhört, genau, ja. Und zwar ist ja der Test am Hauptbahnhof jetzt mit der Gesichtserkennung...
Nee, nicht Hauptbahnhof.
Ja, Südbahnhof, Entschuldigung. Südkreuz. Südkreuz. Ist ja in die Verlängerung gegangen wegen durchschlangenen Erfolgs, die sie aber leider nicht nur mir spezifiziert haben, sondern...
Das ist auch wirklich inkommodierend für mich, weil nämlich, wenn ich aus München mit ihm zukomme, steige ich da raus und in die S-Bahn um. So, das hat mich also echt geärgert, dass sie ausgerechnet da ihre scheiß Gesicht-Dings machen. Und dann ist es so, dass sie das versucht haben, optional zu machen. Ja, das heißt, du hast irgendwie so einen fetten Eingang. Und dann haben sie da so Schilder angehängt und auf der linken Seite steht ohne Gesichtskontrolle. Und auf der rechten Seite steht mit Gesichtskontrolle. Und du hast dann so ein Array von Kameras installiert und denkst so, das kann mir doch keiner erzählen, dass sie nur die rechte Hälfte mitnehmen. Aber gut, du denkst so, okay, schwamm drüber, gehst rauf und dann ist da so eine Rolltreppe. Und unten am Fuß der Rolltreppe ist der Boden beschriftet, wieder irgendwie rechts mit, links ohne. Aber die Rolltreppe, die von oben runterkommt, kommt rechts raus. Und von oben siehst du das noch nicht. Das ist so richtig für die Tonne, so richtig für den Fuß. Du kommst einfach runter, denkst so, Leute, ernsthaft, ja, ernsthaft? Also...
Aber vielleicht erfassen sie nur auf dem Hochweg.
Bestimmt.
Bestimmt. Bestimmt sind sie total ehrlich.
Nein, aber also das ist ja alles, ist auch so ein Technologie getrieben, diese Gesichtserkennung, Geschichte. Das ist irgendwie... Ich hab ja in meiner Kindheit Night Rider geguckt. Ich glaube, da kommt es her. Ja, das oder wo gab es die erste Gesichtserkennung in so...
In der Sci-Fi?
Populär. Also Star Trek war es nicht, denn Star Trek hat einfach, der wusste wer du bist. Du hast irgendwie auf dein...
Dein Transponder, ja.
Genau.
Ich weiß es nicht genau. Also...
Sollen wir Konstanze fragen, die sammelt sowas ja.
Naja, stimmt. Oder vielleicht können uns ja die Hörer noch irgendwie...
Aber ich glaube so Night Rider erinnere ich mich an so Szenen, wie dann irgendwie, der geht die Polizeiakten durch und blendet jedes Bild ein, so dieses Alte.
CSI hatte auch ganz viel.
Ja, CSI ist aber viel später.
Ja, stimmt.
Aber ich glaube, die haben in ihrer Jugend alle diese 80s irgendwie Fernsehkost gesehen und dann gesagt, das will ich haben, wenn ich mal alt bin und für die Polizei arbeite, will ich das haben. Und dann kommt irgendeiner und verspricht ihn auf dem Golfplatz.
Das kriegen wir hin.
Kein Problem. Das läuft.
Wir haben jetzt Maschinen-Learning.
Und das wird gekauft. Ja, so erkläre auch mal den Unterschied zwischen Maschinen-Learning und KI.
Naja, was ist da für ein Unterschied?
Das ist auch so ein Bluthochdruck-Ding, oder? Für manche Leute?
Naja, also...
Dass die Leute immer so tun, als sei das KI, wenn du Maschinen-Learning machst.
Naja, dieser ganze Begriff künstliche Intelligenz ist sowieso Bullshit, ne? Also das ist halt irgendwie ja nur die...
Was ist denn hier los? Gleich kommt die Decke runter.
Ich hoffe nicht, das sind Schleiträger. Also letztendlich war ja künstliche Intelligenz immer nur so das Schlagwort, also eigentlich ja auch eher so ein bisschen so das abfällige Schlagwort, mit dem man diese Zottel, die da hinten in der Informatik halt noch in dem dunklen Gang saßen.
Das waren so Utopisten.
Genau, die halt daran dachten, also glaubten, dass man halt irgendwie ein Mind bauen kann, also ein Gehirn oder ein denkendes System, was also tatsächlich zur logischen Schlussfolgerung in der Lage ist und irgendwie...
Nicht nur das....
und Bewusstsein hat und irgendwie...
Und haben das Versprechen damit verbunden? Also es gab, es gibt diesen Begriff der Kybernetik, das könnt ihr auch mal nachgucken auf Wikipedia. Es gab die Idee sozusagen im Kampf der Systeme zwischen zwischen Kapitalismus und Kommunismus, waren auch viele Kapitalisten der Meinung, dass eine zentrale Planung an sich gut wäre, aber es können Menschen nicht leisten, ohne von Korruption oder so betroffen zu werden, oder die Daten sind inkomplett. Und dann gab es eben diese Utopie, dass man das einfach einen Computer machen lässt und den füttert man mit so viel Daten wie möglich. Und diese Idee hat sich bis heute gehalten, dass es einfach daran liegt, dass wir noch nicht genug Daten haben. Und deswegen sieht man einfach links und rechts Leute irgendwie Daten zusammentragen, völlig sinnlos. Und dann füttert man damit irgendwelche Software. Und die Methoden, mit denen man so Mustererkennung macht, also das ist keine künstliche Intelligenz. Künstliche Intelligenz ist ein, dann unterteilt man in Experten-Systeme. Das sind Sachen, die sind auf einem bestimmten Teilgebiet fähig, aber verstehen nicht, was sie tun. Zum Beispiel ein Experten-System wäre sowas wie, man macht Fotos von einem Patienten und der Computer kann dann erkennen, ob das wie Hautkrebs aussieht oder nicht. Durch eine Bilderkennung Software und sowas. Das ist, was man mit Machine Learning macht heutzutage. Diese Art von Sachen. Aber eine generelle künstliche Intelligenz soll eigentlich mehr können. Soll sowas können, wie eine in Sprache reinkommende Anfrage zu verstehen und beantworten zu können.
Keine Möglichkeit von künstlicher Intelligenz.
Das ist natürlich eine Definitionsfrage.
Die bessere Definition ist halt einfach zu sagen, es gibt halt irgendwie General AI, also halt quasi eine dem menschlichen Hirn irgendwie ähnliche generische künstliche Intelligenz und es gibt Narrowband AI, das heißt also die einzelne Fähigkeiten des menschlichen Hirns abbildet und die dann halt dafür sehr gut, also wie zum Beispiel Mustererkennung oder Autofahren oder sonst irgendwie solche Dinge, die halt also soll man nur einen schmalen Teil der Fähigkeiten machen und da sind wir gerade.
Also das muss man auch noch mal trennen. Autofahren können die nicht, die haben nicht verstanden, dass sie ein Auto fahren. Es ist keine Maschine, die verstanden hat, was ein Auto ist, sondern es ist...
Zum Autofahren muss ich es auch nicht verstehen.
Ja, das ist aber genau der...
Deswegen ist er Narrow.
Das ist der wichtige, ja, aber darauf will ich gerade hinaus. Das ist der Teil, den man verstehen muss. Was wir verstanden haben, was wir können, ist sowas wie Mustererkennung, also sehr eng begrenzte kognitive Sachen nachbauen. Ja, wir können Software bauen, der gibt mal ein Foto und die erkennt ein Schild. Und was das zu Machine Learning macht und nicht zum Algorithmus ist, dass da nicht ein Mensch sitzt und Code programmiert, der ein Schild erkennt, sondern man trainiert das mit Fotos von Bildern, von Schildern. Das heißt, die Software ist in der Lage, selbst Feature Extraction zu machen oder vielleicht assistiert man ein bisschen und kann dann irgendwie erkennen, das ist hier ein quadratisches Etwas und sieht aus, wie ein Schild, auf dem 30 kmh steht. Also sowas kann man machen, aber die Software hat dann nicht verstanden. Das ist ein Schild, was die Regierung aufstellt, damit du 30 kmh fährst, sondern da sitzt dann ein Stück Kot, was sagt, wenn du ein 30 Schild fährst, darfst du nicht schneller fahren als 30. Das heißt, so die Regeln sind immer noch programmiert im Moment, aber der Teil davor ist gelernt. Und es gibt auch Einsätze, ob man das nicht komplett lernen kann. Das ist sozusagen ein wichtiger Schritt auf dem Weg der KI-Forschung. Und Google macht da gerade Schlagzeilen, weil sie einen Schach-Computer gebaut haben, der sich eben die Regeln von Schach auch selbst beigebracht hat. Der hat halt Partien beobachtet. Und da gab es dann niemanden, der irgendwie eine Bewertungsfunktion gemacht hat, die assistiert wird von irgendwelchen...
Nein, das stimmt nicht ganz. Also was sie da getan haben, nachdem was wir sehen können, ist halt, dass sie die Optimierungskriterien halt relativ weit fassen konnten. Also darum geht es eigentlich am Ende gerade, dass man also Methoden sucht, um die... also entweder die Auswahl von verschiedenen Optimierungskriterien von Machine Learning machen zu lassen. Das heißt sozusagen, Machine Learning herausfinden zu lassen, ob für das Problem, was es gerade lösen soll, welcher von den ungefähr 400 bekannten Methoden halt irgendwie so ein Optimierungslernen zu machen, halt der Sinnvolle dafür ist. Und damit kann man halt Experten wegratsionalisieren, uns halt sehr viel schneller machen. Und die andere Methode, die sie halt dazu, wo AlphaZero verwendet haben, war halt, also offenbar, weil es da nicht publik ist, wir sehen nur die Ergebnisse und doch die sind zum Teil ein bisschen umstritten, wo Leute sagen so, naja, also da habt ihr schon sehr selektiv gearbeitet.
Naja, wir sehen noch ein paar Behauptungen von Ihnen.
Paper hält nicht stand und die Behauptungen sind halt irgendwie so ein bisschen fragwürdig. Aber anyway, nehmen wir es mal so, wie es halt da ist. Und dann, was wir da halt sehen, ist halt eine Methode mit sehr hoher Lernrechenaufwand. Also, die haben halt zwar nicht allzu viel Stunden damit zugebracht, aber sehr, sehr viele Prozessoren dafür verwendet. Und zwar spezialisierte Prozessoren, diese Intensore Processing Units. Und die denen halt sehr, sehr viele Schachpartien gegeben. Und bei Schach hast du ja ein implizites Bewertungssystem, nämlich wie viele Punkte kommen am Ende dabei raus. Also wie viel Zügen schaffst du es, den Gegner matt zu setzen oder in wie viel Prozent der Partien gewinnst du. Also das heißt, das Optimierungsreferentum ist vollkommen klar. Musst du also nicht einprogrammieren. Was sie aber tun mussten, war halt natürlich die Regeln, also die Regeln reintun, also welche Züge überhaupt möglich sind. Und dann halt noch ein bisschen an den Kriterien rumspielen. Und dann haben sie halt den sehr überraschenden und relativ beeindruckenden Erfolg geschafft, dass sie es geschafft haben, dass das Ding quasi Schach aus der Beobachtung von Schachpartien lernt. So wie ein Mensch lernen würde. Also der auch zwar die Regeln lernt, aber dann halt einfach sehr viel Schach spielt und aus der Erfahrung wird er ein guter Schachspieler. Und genau deshalb hat dieses System auch getan. Das hat sehr viele Partien, also die Daten von so Schachpartien gibt es irgendwie millionenfach im Netz. Und daran haben sie es halt lernen lassen und daraus dann halt eben die entsprechenden Strategien irgendwie abzuzweigen. Und das ist relativ beeindruckend, aber es ist halt ein Trend, den wir jetzt gerade an vielen Stellen sehen, ist Recurrent Machine Learning. Recurrent Machine Learning, wo zum Beispiel NVIDIA hingegangen ist und gesagt hat, okay, dieses Ganze gefummelt mit irgendwie, wir bringen ihm die Verkehrsschilder bei und wo eine Straße ist und die Bilderkennung und diese ganzen Dinge, ist uns alles viel zu kompliziert. Wir nehmen einfach mal irgendwie nur mal zu gucken, ob es geht. Rein als Experiment nehmen wir mal so einen dicken NVIDIA Machine Learning Prozessor, also auf der Basis von ihren Grafikkarten, schnallen den in so ein Auto, tun ein paar Kameras ran und lassen das Ding einfach zugucken, wie jemand mit der Kraue rumfährt. Und so live, so dass jemand mit der Kraue rumgefahren ist. Und dann haben sie halt das Ding irgendwie lernen lassen und haben ihm halt ein bisschen Feedback gegeben. Und am Ende konnte das Ding halt irgendwie sogar Feldwege fahren. Also der Testdaten-Satz, den sie da als Video rausgelassen haben, war natürlich wieder so ein paar Fragwürdigkeiten. Da waren natürlich Sachen bei, wo man schon gesehen hat, dass sie Sachen weggelassen haben. Und dass es halt jetzt auch nicht überall so super geklappt hat.
Haben halt den Teil gezeigt, der funktioniert hat.
Aber der Teil, der funktioniert hat, war halt schon relativ beeindruckend. Also dass es halt irgendwie möglich ist, halt tatsächlich diese Systeme lernen zu lassen. Wie zum Beispiel halt auch Computerspiele. Also es gibt halt so für die meisten klassischen Computerspiele, gibt es mittlerweile so Machine-Learning-Experimente, wo sie der Engine halt im Wesentlichen nur gesagt haben, so was ist denn gut? Nämlich hoher Punktestand. Und haben dann halt irgendwie das Ding selber versucht lassen, rauszukriegen, was irgendwie aus den Pixeln muss, wie Breakout zum Beispiel.
Und die haben dann beschissen, stellt sich raus.
Genau, die haben halt alles genommen, was geht. Die müssen ja nicht in den Regen spielen. Das können sie machen, wie sie wollen.
Also was mir ganz wichtig ist als Beobachtung, wenn der Computer tatsächlich so lernt wie ein Mensch, dann wird er auch genauso Unfälle machen wie ein Mensch. Also das Versprechen von selbstfahrenden Autos ist ja unter anderem, dass man dann keine Unfälle mehr hat, weil die sich immer perfekt an die Verkehrsregeln halten. Das tun sie aber nur, wenn die einprogrammiert sind, nicht wenn die irgendwie gelernt sind. Dann kann man das nicht mit Sicherheit sagen, dass sie sich an die halten.
Also tatsächlich ist also die, also meine Vermutung ist, dass halt dieses Pure Learning beim Autofahren auch erstmal eine Weile nicht zur Anwendung kommen wird, weil genau dieses Problem auftritt. Aber an vielen anderen Stellen werden wir das halt schon sehen. Und die ist halt ein cooler Perastand, das muss man völlig neidlos anerkennen. Also interessant daran finde ich halt, dass die, dass der erste algorithmische Durchbruch seit einer Weile ist, wo also die, also die letztendliche Leistung des Systems nicht durch nur mehr Hardware drauf kippen gestiegen ist.
Aber größtenteils.
Über noch größtenteils. Also tatsächlich ist es auch so, dass man schon sagen kann, dass also viele von den Erfolgen, die wir zu sehen haben im Machine Learning, haben halt einfach damit zu tun, dass halt die großen Firmen nicht nur sehr viele Daten haben, mit denen sie halt irgendwie das Learning betreiben können, sondern auch enorm viele Computer haben, auf denen sie halt irgendwie, je mehr man halt da Learning-Cycles betreibt, desto besser wird es halt. Und daraus entsteht halt ja gerade schon so ein gewisser, naja, so eine Monopol-Situation. Also, dass also die Firmen, die halt in der Lage sind, da wirklich was zu reißen und von denen halt auch die meisten coolen Papers kommen, sind halt die Chinesen, also halt irgendwie Tencent und Co., die halt und Baidu, die halt irgendwie auf echt großen Datenmengen sitzen und sehr viele Processing-Capacities haben, sind die Google-Leute.
Da bin ich sehr vorsichtig, weil gerade Google hat eben ihren Scheiß nicht nur Open Source größtenteils, sondern bietet ihre Tensor-Units auch als Cloud-Buchbar an. Das heißt, die versuchen, natürlich kostet das anständig Geld, klar, aber es ist nicht so, dass sie die Technologie im dunklen Kämmerlein horten, sondern die möchten schon auch. Ich mache mir eher Sorgen an der anderen Seite, dass wenn Entscheidungen auf Basis von Machine-Learning getroffen wurden, dass man dann im Grunde nicht mehr sagen kann, warum. Und wir sehen im Moment so einen Trend hin zu sowohl Predictive Policing als auch Computer-assistierte Urteile. Da gab es jetzt den ersten Fall, der so ein bisschen anrüchtig war. In den USA, da ging es nämlich um einen Richter, der computerassistiertes Strafmaß bestimmt hat in einem Fall. Und der Computer hat halt genau getan, wie er programmiert wurde und hat gesagt, wie maximal Strafe und sogar, ich glaube, mehr noch als die Staatsanwaltschaft gefordert hat.
Das hat eine Empfehlung abgegeben, ne?
Mit der, also hat es natürlich nicht irgendwie, ja. Aber der Richter, das Problem ist halt, wenn du so ein Computer hast, wirst du am Anfang vielleicht noch vorsichtig sein, aber dann siehst du das ein paar Mal funktionieren und dann vertraust du dem halt. Das heißt, das ist aus meiner Sicht ein Feigenblatt. Ja, dieses Urteil war, also diese Empfehlung hieß, irgendwie fast Maximalstrafe. Mit der Begründung, das ist irgendwie ein gewaltbereiter Intensivtäter. Und das können wir sehen, weil irgendwie die Daten, die wir haben, zudem sagt seine Familie sitzt auch größtenteils im Knast, weißt du so oft, also Indizien, die statistisch gesehen durchaus alle valide sind.
Korrelation.
Ja, Korrelation, die nachvollziehbar sind. Das war jetzt noch nicht mal irgendwie Machine Learning.
Einfach Statistik.
Einfach Statistik. Aber da kam dann natürlich die Frage auf, ob da nicht, also das ist eine Debatte, die gerade in den Medien ziemlich dumm geführt wird, aber die an der Stelle durchaus illustrierbar ist, ob da nicht rassistische Gedanken einfach in Form von Statistiken perpetuiert werden.
Nein, nicht nur rassistische, sondern alle möglichen Formen von Status Quo.
Ja, aber eben auch rassistische Sachen.
Also alle Formen von Diskriminierung. Natürlich. Also alle möglichen Dinge, die halt, also jetzt, was war jetzt gerade irgendwie das System, mit dem Apple halt irgendwie seine Gesichtserkennung macht, was offensichtlich halt mit Chinesen Probleme hat, ja?
Na gut, aber mit einem Fall. Und bei, das also rein von den Zahlen her, ob das jetzt zwei Chinesen oder zwei, zwei Weiße oder zwei Schwarze. Aber das war natürlich, der rassistische Joke schrieb sich von selbst. Wie ich im Blog schrieb, war ja klar.
Nee, aber tatsächlich ist diese, diese Frage halt, welche Form von Bias encoded man an sein Trainingset, ist halt so ein Gebiet, auf dem wir noch sehr, sehr viel Forschung brauchen. Also wo auch, ich bin ja immer so ein bisschen vorsichtig mit diesem ganzen, so was wir alles irgendwie an politisch korrekten Dingen in Technologie encoden müssen. Aber an dieser Stelle muss ich schon sagen, ist halt offensichtlich und absehbar, dass also die, wenn man halt Technologie bauen will, die für die gesamte Menschheit funktioniert, dann muss halt die gesamte Menschheit im Trainingsdatensatz sein. Und dann müssen halt irgendwie alle Dinge, die halt so Menschen voneinander für einen Computer schwerer und unterscheidbar machen, müssen halt encoded werden.
Das ist übrigens würde ich nicht auf Computer beschränken. Das ist genauso, wenn du sagst, das ist irgendwie Erfahrungsschatz der Polizei. Es gab neulich so einen Artikel, der mich ziemlich mitgenommen hat. Da ging es irgendwie darum, dass ein Kripo-Beamter ausgesagt hat, dass sie dann eine Quote haben. Ich glaube, es war Hamburg. Und wenn die zum Wochenende ihre Quote nicht drin haben, dann gehen sie nochmal zum Hauptbahnhof und da hängen die ganzen Ausländer rum und da finden sie dann immer...
Irgendwie finden sie schon, ne?
Genau, das sagt ihnen sozusagen ihre kriminalistische Erfahrung. Das ist halt ein Schwerpunkt. Ja, so. Aber das ist jetzt natürlich, auf der einen Seite kann man sagen, naja, also wenn das Kriminelle sind, ist es doch in Ordnung, wenn die weggeleucht werden, ne? So, auf der anderen Seite kannst du aber sagen, was sagt denn das über die Statistik, aus die am Ende rauskommt?
Die dann selbst verstärken wird.
Das ist ein selbst verstärkender Prozess. Und jetzt denken wir uns die nächste Iteration. Da wird jetzt ein Computer betrainiert und der sagt, ja, am Hauptbahnhof sind offensichtlich die ganzen Kriminellen. Aber wer sagt denn, wenn die jetzt nicht zum Hauptbahnhof, sondern, was weiß ich, zum Saturn in der Mall gegangen wären, ob sie da nicht auch Kriminelle gefunden hätten? Ja, dann halt keine Ausländer oder vielleicht auch. Also, was weiß ich? Ja, ist auch egal, wen sie da gefunden hätten. Aber wenn Teil von der Herleitung der Statistik so entsteht, dass Leute gezielt dahingehen, weil sie glauben, da gibt's mehr, dann sieht es auch danach in der Statistik so aus, als wenn da mehr wären. Ob das jetzt so ist oder nicht. Und diese Effekte sieht man halt nicht, wenn man so einen Computer trainiert. Daher ist das eine Verstärkung von dem Problem an der Stelle.
Und die also die Frage, halt wie man so was abbildet und was halt irgendwie Möglichkeiten sind, dem gegenzusteuern, wenn wir auf dem Kongress auch diskutieren, also auf dem Kongress ein paar Talks, so die in diese Richtung gehen, halt also so Machine Learning Biases und was da heute schon so an Problemen auftritt und wie man da möglicherweise gegensteuern könnte. Und was mich da halt immer daran interessiert, ist halt also diese Frage von Technologie als Machtverstärker und Machtzementierer. Und da muss man klar sagen, ist die Frage, für welchen Zweck wende ich dieses Machine Learning an, ist nicht mehr neutral. Also wir können nicht mehr die Behauptung aufstellen, dass irgendwie die Anwendung von Technologie da apolitisch ist. Sondern man muss halt klar sagen, dass Systeme, die solche Macht haben, gerade insbesondere wenn es um Nudging und so weiter geht, dass die Diskussion darüber, wofür die angewendet werden, wie die trainiert werden, für welche Zwecke die eingesetzt werden, was das Ziel ihres Einsatzes ist, dass die auf jeden Fall transparent gemacht werden. Also dass also tatsächlich nicht mal irgendjemand so ein System betreiben kann, ohne seine Optimierungskriterien offen zu legen. Und selbst wenn man halt sagt, die Systeme werden nicht perfekt sein und die gibt halt irgendwie andere Konsequenzen, also all diese ganzen Dinge nebenbei, will ich trotzdem erstmal wissen, was sind eigentlich die Optimierungskriterien, auf die das System trainiert wurde. Und ich finde, die müssen offengelegt werden. Also es ist tatsächlich eine Transparenzpflicht, die man halt einfach genauso wie man halt bei einer Chemieanlage offenlegen muss, was da irgendwie für Chemikalien drin verarbeitet werden, die möglicherweise die Umgebung beeinträchtigen können, müssen wir bei Machine Learning Systemen die Optimierungskriterien und im Zweifel sogar die Training-Sets offen haben.
So und jetzt gehen wir mal einen Schritt weiter.
Also mindestens wenn es um Systeme geht, wo Menschen betroffen sind.
Ja, aber jetzt denk doch mal zurück an was du vorhin beschrieben hast, dass es inzwischen Verfahren gibt, um die Optimierungskriterien selber mit Machine Learning zu selektieren. Das heißt, wir haben da eine Indirektion drin und es ist vielleicht gar nicht mehr nachvollziehbar, was das eigentlich, wie es jetzt zu diesem dazu gekommen ist.
Das sind halt die Meteroptimierungskriterien, die du halt offenlegen musst.
Ja, aber ich will mal eine etwas fundamentalistische Kritik an der Stelle äußern, denn wir können seit vielen Jahren beobachten, dass Software eine Sache ist, für die keiner haftet, wenn da Fehler drin sind. Ja, also Software wird einfach inzwischen angenommen, hat halt Fehler, Produkthaftung greift nicht und das heißt aber auch, dass es für Hersteller günstig ist, Sachen in Software zu machen, weil wenn dann da was schief geht, dann ist es ein Softwarefehler. Und dann hat man am besten eine Updatepipeline und kann irgendwie ein Update einspielen, was das fixt und dann ist wieder gut. Und wenn wir jetzt aber Machine Learning aus dem Kontext sehen, dass es ein Vehikel ist, um Dinge zu tun, die man schon immer tun wollte, aber so kommt man aus der Haftung raus. Prozesse, die wir bisher mit Menschen machen, die fehlbar sind und da gibt es aber immer wieder Ärger mit. Und also Gerichtsverfahren finde ich das offensichtliche Beispiel an der Stelle, dass wir das, wenn wir das anfangen mit Machine Learning und KI-Systemen zu machen, dass wir dann unsere gesamte Welt auf ein Fundament bauen, in dem keiner mehr für irgendwelche Probleme haftet, sondern das war dann halt ein Softwareproblem. Ja, das heißt, wir werden nur noch alles, ich meine, das ist jetzt schon ein echter Trend. Das ist immer irgendwie aus technischen Gründen.
Deswegen bin ich ja dafür zu sagen, es muss bei solchen Systemen immer jemand geben, der verantwortlich ist für dieses System, also der tatsächlich eine benennbare, so wie der einzige Teil, der bei diesem Netzwerk durchsetzten gesetzlich sinnvoll ist, dass es halt eine Stelle geben muss, wo man jemand erreicht von so einem Netzwerk, wenn man eine Beschwerde hat. So und genau so was muss es halt für solche Systeme auch geben. Es muss halt für jedes dieser Systeme, die halt da irgendwie mit Machine Learning, mit Daten arbeiten, die Menschen betreffen, muss es halt einen benennbaren Verantwortlichen geben. Und dieser Verantwortliche muss einem ganz, ganz schlecht unterliegen.
Ja, aber das ist notwendig, aber nicht hinreichend.
Nee, das ist notwendig. Damit können wir erst mal überhaupt anfangen, drüber nachzudenken, was dann passiert. Weil ganz viel werden wir gerade einfach schlicht nicht sehen. So, weil die Optimierungskriterien zum Beispiel, die halt irgendwie so Personalgewertungssysteme anlegen.
Ja, da hängen Menschen nebenan.
Da hängen Menschen nebenan. So oder wenn, also selbst wenn man ein relativ einfaches Machine Learning nimmt, was nun nichts weiter ist als eigentlich Fernsehstatistik. Also wo jetzt einfach mal nicht mehr diese Koalitionen, die daraus destilliert werden können, sind ja häufig, naja, halt nur Tendenzaussagen, auf denen dann aber wiederum Leute halt ihre Optimierungskriterien basieren. Und deswegen ist halt dieser Anspruch zu sagen, so je größer und mächtiger so eine Entität ist, desto mehr müssen die Transparenzansprüche an die hochgeschraubt werden. Und desto weniger müssen die mit personenbezogenen Daten arbeiten dürfen. So das finde ich eine Metrik, mit der man arbeiten kann zu sagen. Je größer so eine Entität ist, desto weniger persönliche Daten soll sie verarbeiten dürfen. Und desto mehr muss sie halt offenlegen, was sie da eigentlich tut. Und mir geht es da primär nicht um sowas wie ein Algorithmus-TÜV oder sowas, weil der ist halt vor dem Hintergrund von Recurrent Machine Learning totaler Bullshit, sondern ums Offenlegen von den Business-Zielen. Weil auch wenn du so ein Recurrent Machine Learning-System hast, wo du eigentlich nicht mehr verstehst im Detail, was es tut, wird es von Menschen für Geld betrieben, die Leute dafür bezahlen, es zu programmieren, die Maschinen dafür bezahlen, es auszuführen, mit einem Zweck, einem Ziel. Und dieses Ziel muss im Zweifel sich einer gesellschaftlichen Kontrolle unterwerfen können.
Ja, aber das ist alles so Feuerwehr. Irgendwie das Haus brennt. Was machen wir jetzt?
Nee, warte, nicht löschen.
Nein, du hast völlig recht. Aber ich will sagen, ich habe ein tiefes Unwohlsein, weil mich das auch so ein bisschen an diese Finanzkrise erinnert, wenn ihr das noch auf dem Schirm habt. Die haben ja auch ein ähnliches Problem gehabt, dass sie so lauter Wertpapiere hatten, die im Grunde wertlos waren und haben die dann mit anderen Sachen zusammengetan und haben so eine Kaskade aus Schritten gebaut, damit am Ende keiner mehr nachvollziehen konnte, ist das jetzt ordentlich oder nicht? Und genau das sehe ich gerade mit KI und Softwareentwicklung den Trend, dass wir immer komplexere Systeme bauen und vielleicht nicht mit kriminellen Zielen, das am Ende keiner mehr verstehen kann. Aber das indirekte Ziel ist es meines Erachtens auf jeden Fall, dass keiner die Verantwortung übernehmen will. Und wie genau, wie beim BER, wenn jetzt halt so viele Leute an den Problemen beschäftigt, dass am Ende keiner mehr schuld ist. Und da muss man entgegenwirken, nicht indem man irgendwelche Transparenzgeschichten macht. Die sind auch notwendig. Aber das ist nicht die Lösung, sondern das ist eher so, was machen wir denn jetzt? Also wenn man das lösen will, muss man die Komplexität der Systeme um uns herum begrenzen. Anders geht es nicht. Man muss sagen, Systeme, von denen Menschenleben abhängen, müssen höchstens so komplex sein, dass sie noch nachvollziehbar sind. Ja, vielleicht nicht deterministisch. Ich weiß nicht, ob man das fordern kann oder ob der Zug abgefahren ist. Aber wir geben das gerade komplett aus der Hand, nachvollziehen zu können, wie Entscheidungen gefällt wurden. Und das ist ein Riesenrisiko, was meines Erachtens viel zu wenig.
Ich will da mal kurz ein bisschen gegenhalten. Letzten Eines kann man sich ja so ein Maschinensystem vorstellen wie ein Haustier. Das hat halt, also mit Haustieren haben wir gelernt, umzugehen. Also so ein Hund, so ist halt ja durchaus jetzt nicht so völlig vorhersagbar, ist kein deterministisches Viech. Wenn die ein bisschen größer sind, ist der durchaus in der Lage, dich umzubringen, wenn er schlechte Laune hat. Aber wir sind in der Lage einzuschätzen, wie so ein Hund so drauf ist. Und der wird trainiert, der wird halt irgendwie abgerichtet im Sinne von einem Training. Und das unterscheidet sich nicht allzu sehr von so einem Machine Learning Training. Das ist halt positives und negatives Feedback, was halt so ein Tier kriegt. Und dann verhält er sich halt entsprechend. Aber es hat halt eine eigene Persönlichkeit. Es hat halt eine eigene, trifft halt Entscheidungen. Es reagiert halt auf Reize. Und die sind halt zum Teil halt irgendwie, führen die halt dazu, dass so ein Hund sich halt daneben benimmt. Oder halt irgendwie Leute verletzt. Selbiges mit einem Pferd oder so, ne?
Ja, aber du würdest einen Hund nicht Auto fahren lassen. Sondern was du mit einem Hund machst, wo Menschenleben von abhängen, sind so entweder Hilfsjob für irgendwie blinden Hund, ne? Da stimm ich dir zu.
Aber die Menschen haben ja viele Jahrtausende mit Pferdenauto gefahren.
Ja, aber nicht, das war nicht, wenn das Pferd irgendwie schlechte Laune hat.
Dann ist es durchgegangen und Leute sind umgekommen, und zwar nicht ganz wenige. Pferde durchgehen war irgendwie tatsächlich irgendwie so lange Pferde, wie viel Transportlaubs benutzt wird.
Ich seh schon das Argument von dir hier gerade.
Tatsächlich, und da haben wir uns halt daran gewöhnt, weil wir so lange mit denen zu tun haben. Und weil es halt sozusagen ein kulturelles, tradiertes Wissen darüber gibt, wie so ein Pferd reagiert, weil man es gezüchtet hat darauf, dass es möglichst irgendwie ein ruhiger Geselle ist. Und Pferd hat scheu klappen bekommen. So, und es gab halt trainierte Menschen für den Umgang damit, nämlich die Kutscher, so und so. Tatsächlich kann man schon durchaus vergleichen. Es ist ein sehr, sehr komplexes System. Der Kutscher hat keine Ahnung davon, wie es gehören von so einem Pferd funktioniert. Der kann ja auch nicht die Neurolin darin aufzählen. Aber er weiß halt, dass so ein Pferd halt erschreckt, wenn es halt irgendwie so... Und ich glaube, dass der Umgang mit KI, den wir finden werden, insbesondere mit so einem Machine-Learning-System, wird ein ähnlicher sein. Aber bei Pferden war es dann halt eben so, dass es halt irgendwie einen kulturellen und gesellschaftlichen Druck dahin gab, Rassen zu züchten, die halt verträglich sind, bei denen die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass es durchgeht, geringer ist. Da gab es auch eine Erfahrung darin, wie man die trainiert und abrichtet. Es gab auch sozusagen über das Optimierungsziel, es gab halt verschiedene Optimierungsziele, es gab Rennpferde und Brauereiferde und Ackerpferde und so, aber die Optimierungsziele waren relativ klar. Da war dann nichts Überraschendes dabei. Und ich glaube, das ist so eine Analogie, die man ein bisschen mehr heranziehen muss, dass man sagt, okay, wir müssen als Gesellschaft im Zweifel einen Umgang damit entwickeln, der eben auch sagt, bestimmte Sachen machst du nicht. Also zum Beispiel ist es halt eben so, dass du darfst, in Deutschland zum Beispiel, darfst du ja keine Hunde-Rassen auf erhöhte Aggressivität züchten. Oder abrichten. Also es ist halt tatsächlich so, wenn du das tust, dann kannst du dein Recht, Hunde zu halten, verwirken. Und das tatsächlich...
Die meisten Länder sind nahe auf das, dass das passiert ist.
Machen sie einen Gutachten.
Na, das ist doch aber auch Bullshit.
Nö, ist nicht Bullshit, funktioniert ganz gut.
Also ich will da mal gegenhalten, uber.
Ja, muss man einfach verbieten, ist ja nicht weiter schlimm.
Ja, aber ich meine, das ist doch das Problem, dass du sozusagen dann gegen den Markt wirst.
Wir müssen einfach unsere Scheu davor verlieren, Businessmodelle zu verbieten. Warum sollten wir so was dulden? Es gibt keinen Grund dafür.
Ja, ich bin ganz auf deiner Seite, aber ich sehe das nicht passieren, weil einfach da Kohle verdient wird mit.
Ne, Uber verdient keine Kohle, Uber verbrennt eine Milliarde Dollar pro Jahr.
Ja, aber so in Richtung, na Moment, also das ist eigentlich, eigentlich ist Uber eigentlich Kommunismus, ist ein großer Plan, der nicht funktioniert und verteilt Geld um von reichen Investoren an arme Programmierer. Und macht aber tatsächlich, aber ist ein unmoralischer Haufen von den Herren. Es gab noch nicht so ein Video, da hat sich ein ehemaliger Sun-Mitarbeiter hat sich über Uber aufgeregt und es ging so darum, dass Firmen unmoralisch sind und er hat dann so ein Video gezeigt, wie ein selbstfahrendes Uber-Auto über eine rote Ampel fährt und meinte, das ist in San Francisco und hier an der Ecke ist ein Kindergarten. Und erzählte dann sein Kind war auf diesem Kindergarten. Und da dachte ich mir so, okay, also das ist der Moment, wo ich verstehe, warum die Amis alle Schusswaffen kaufen. Weißt du, weil da wäre ich aber auch irgendwie, wenn irgendein ein Arschloch, weißt du, so ein Start-up-Fatzke aus Geldspargründen seine KI nicht ordentlich programmiert und mein Kind platt fährt, dann wäre ich aber auch ein Schusswaffenbesitzer, sag ich dir. Aber also ich sehe das halt nicht, dass man das regulieren kann, weil einfach im Moment es genau andersrum abläuft, dass diese Firmen sozusagen den Rest vor sich her treiben. Was da gerade passiert ist, dass dann noch Leute Geld hinwerfen, verstehe ich seit Jahren nicht auf Uber.
Na gut, also Uber hat, also Ubers Idee dabei war halt einfach, dass sie den Markt halt irgendwie monopolisiert bekommen. Und die Leute dann halt irgendwie daran gewöhnt sind, dass sie halt Uber fahren und dann fahren sie halt über, wenn es halt irgendwie automatisierte Autos sind. So und was die halt, also deren Kernfehler ist halt, dass sie völlig übersehen haben, dass die Leute mittlerweile halt die App, mit der sie halt irgendwie Auto fahren, wechseln wie die Unterhose, wenn es halt drauf ankommt, gibt es halt irgendwie für die keinen Grund, nicht irgendwie Lift oder irgendwas anderes zu nehmen. Oder wenn mein Autohersteller sagt, hier übrigens, ich hab jetzt irgendwie auch ein, irgendwie autonomes Car Service, du musst dein Auto nicht mehr kaufen, hier ist irgendwie das Auto, wann immer du es brauchst. Warum sogar noch jemand Uber benutzen soll? Also die haben sich verzockt, da bin ich vollkommen sicher. Wofür Uber steht, ist halt diese Disruption Ideologie. Also dieses, und das Interessante daran ist, dass es gerade gegen die Wand fährt, auch in der gesellschaftlichen Akzeptanz. Also was gerade im Wellen passiert, ist super spannend. Ja, ja, dass also die, diese neuen Villains, ja, also tatsächlich sind die Super Villains, also die, die großen, diese großen Unicorn-Start-ups werden tatsächlich jetzt, also haben jetzt tatsächlich so denselben Ruf wie die Wall Street Banker, weil sie halt insbesondere da auch vor Ort, also so in der Bay Area halt auch in einer Art und Weise agieren, die halt mit den, mit der Computer nichts mehr zu tun hat.
Ja, halt auch mehr kaputt machen, als sie unterm Strich bringen. Also aber sie selber, das finde ich den spannendsten Aspekt dran, kriegen es nicht mit, sondern halten sich immer noch. Also wenn du so in so Start-up-Kreisen unterwegs bist, keine Spur davon, alle so nach wie vor wird das Rappen jetzt hier geil. Wir brauchen nur noch ein bisschen mehr Start-up-Kohle. Und dann Growth Hacking ist so ein Ding. Googelt mal Growth Hacking. Da wird euch speiübel. Das Selbstbild von diesen Start-up-Pfuzzis ist unerträglich.
Also die kognitive Dissonanz, die wir mittlerweile aufwenden müssen, ist halt ganz schon erheblich. Also wenn du halt irgendwie in San Francisco wohnst und du im Wesentlichen irgendwie zwischen Arbeitsplatz, deinem Fitnessstudio und deinem Hochhaus, Apartment und der Panels vielleicht zwischendurch noch saufen gehst und dich zwischen diesen Orten jeweils mit einem Uber bewegst und diesmal beim Aussteigen über Bettler steigen musst, und zwar wirklich literally steigen musst, die halt in der Tür wohnen von deinem Fitnessstudio, dann geht halt irgendwann nur noch so bedingt. Also da kommen halt Leute raus, die halt irgendwie, also ich meine, Soziopathen. Ja, also ich meine, wenn du dir halt auch in denen anguckst, was die, also wie da die Verhältnisse sind. Also da gibt es halt Leute, die leben davon, dass sie in San Francisco, so halbwegs Downtown, eine Sozialwohnung zugesprochen bekommen haben vor vielen Jahren. Und wie leben die davon? Die vermieten die unter über Airbnb oder ein Apartment Sharing Service.
Für unfassbare Kohle.
Für unfassbare Kohle und sind dann halt irgendwie rüber auf die andere Bay-Seite nach Oakland gezogen, in einem eher doch etwas slum-artigen Zone. Und sind aber in dieser Zone wiederum ziemlich reich, weil sie halt irgendwie die Miete von dieser Sozialwohnung, die dann halt zehnfache von dem ist, was sie selber bezahlen.
Oder wohnen in der Karibik, das hab ich auch mal gehört. Ein Typ, der halt irgendwie an den Strand gezogen ist und da wie der König wohnt in Mexiko oder so.
Naja, also es ist vollkommen klar, wie...
Jaja, das Ding, das ist eine Dystopie eigentlich.
Aber ich glaube, das Problem ist halt, dass diese, also wieso es halt implodieren wird. Und das wird dann halt ganz schön hart werden, wenn diese Bubble platzt. Wahrscheinlich so härter als die Bitcoin-Bubble. Falls Bitcoin eine Bubble ist, wir wissen es ja noch nicht. Wenn wir in zwölf Monaten wissen.
Alter, wirklich?
Dann, also wenn dieses Data-Bubble platzt, wird es deswegen so hart sein, weil dann diese gesamte Überzeugung von mit Technologie die Welt retten. Also dieses wir retten, wir lösen unsere Probleme. Und das sind immer so die Bay Area-Probleme, die sie da versuchen zu lösen. Also es sind immer Probleme, die sie selber haben und nicht verstehen, dass ihre Probleme mit dem Rest der Welt eigentlich weitgehend nichts zu tun haben, sodass sie schon, wenn sie nach Boston gehen, auf die andere Seite der USA oder auch noch mal hoch nach Seattle fahren, die Leute diese Probleme meistens nicht haben, die sie da versuchen zu lösen. Und trotzdem rollen sie das dann halt weltweit aus. Und ich glaube, das ist der Grund, wieso es gegen die Wand fahren wird. Und das Problem, was wir jetzt ja schon haben, ist, dass dieses Prinzip Start-up an sich ist ja eigentlich jetzt schon totgelaufen. Es gibt halt keine...
Oh, das sag ich, denke ich seit Jahren.
Nein, nein, Moment, aber...
Woran machst du das fest?
Kannst du begründen. Und zwar, wenn man sich anguckt, worin investiert wird, was VC ist, worin VC ist investieren. Und die haben mittlerweile wird eigentlich in so alles, was nicht relativ hardcore Tech ist, also im Sinne von wirkliche Technologieentwicklung, nur noch sehr zögerlich investiert aus dem Grund, dass die, also wenn die nicht schon etabliert und groß sind, aber jetzt so neue Start-ups, die jetzt so anfangen, so Series A oder früher. Weil die wissen, dass ganz, ganz viele von den möglichen Business-Modellen niemals es bis zum Exit schaffen, weil ihn vorher Google oder Facebook oder Apple oder Microsoft, die nicht mehr kaufen, das machen die schon nur noch sehr selten, oder wenn sie das Team haben wollen, sondern einfach die kopieren. Und dadurch, dass sie halt schon diesen Mindshare haben, weil sie die Menge an Usern halt einfach haben, werden die sich nicht irgendeinen Zusatzservice buchen, den Google drei Wochen später sowieso dann in Google Maps implementiert oder solche Sachen. Sondern die wissen halt irgendwie, wenn Facebook ihnen zumindest theoretisch die Butter vom Brot nehmen kann, ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass aus dem Start-up wird nahezu nur, dann machen sie es nicht. Und wiederum passiert diese Innovation dann aber nicht. Weil allerdings davon ist tatsächlich Innovation nicht nur Bullshit, sondern die passiert dann halt einfach nicht, weil Facebook es halt zwar tun könnte, aber nicht macht. So, das heißt also, was wir gerade sehen, ist ein Abbremsen der Innovationsgeschwindigkeit außerhalb von Hardcore-Technologie-Entwicklung. Ist vielleicht auch nicht verkehrt. Also kann sein, dass es tatsächlich sogar netto gut ist, aber es führt halt dazu.
Aber was gab es denn da für Innovation? Das war doch größtenteils so Bullshit oder nicht? Also ich denke jetzt an so Pet-Grooming und irgendwie Supermarkt-Bringt-dir-Essen-vorbei.
Da gibt es auch durchaus Sachen, wo man sagen kann, also zum Beispiel ein einfaches Beispiel, also was halt durchaus für die Welt hilfreich wäre, wäre ein Service, der mir sagt, wie voll ist es gerade irgendwo? Im Kino, im Supermarkt, im Fitnessstudio, in den Verkehrsmitteln. Wäre einfach trivial zu machen.
Es gibt also ein paar Google Maps inzwischen eingebaut, ne?
Also so ein bisschen.
Von der Umsetzung her vielleicht debattierbar.
Eher so ein bisschen noch so, wie viele Queries haben wir denn da auf dieser Ecke? Aber nicht wie viele Leute sind denn da eigentlich? Könnten sie aber Probleme machen. Unter normalen Umständen würde man sagen, macht man halt einen Startup draus, irgendwie verteilt ein bisschen Technologie, irgendwie baut sich dann eine App drumrum. So, wie man es halt früher gemacht hätte. Wenn du heute mit so einem Businessplan zu so einem VZ gehst, und du sagst, hier würde es funktionieren, hier ist unser Prototyp, wir hätten hier gerne ein paar Millionen dafür. Und das ist irgendwie, keine Ahnung, wenn eine App wurde, halt irgendwie Disruption. Das wäre halt nicht mal eine Disruption. Das wäre tatsächlich nur eine Altersverbesserung. Du nimmst die nicht mehr so weg, du verteilst nur vorhanden.
Bisher macht das der Taxifahrer, der empfiehlt dir halt einen.
Ja, gut, aber das ist zu selten. Also es hat passiert eigentlich nicht. Wer fragt den Taxifahrer danach, welcher Supermarkt gerade vor alles macht?
Nein, nicht Supermarkt, aber Restaurant.
Ja gut, auch der weiß nicht, wie voll es da ist. Der ist vom Restaurant bestochen dafür, dass er dir was bezahlt, nicht dahin bringt.
Hast du irgendeinen Grund, irgendein Start-up zu glauben, dass es dir ordentliche Daten gibt und nicht bezahlt wird?
Da könntest du ja machen. Ich meine, man könnte ja so einen Start-up bauen und sagen, okay, 99 Cent im Monat dafür, dass du die Service benutzen darfst und deine Daten spendest. Könnte man als Geschäftsmodell zumindest mal?
Ich sehe keinen Grund, den zu trauen. Die werden alle sagen, ja klar, bei uns ist Platz. Na klar, kommt zu uns.
Man könnte es ja objektiv messen, wäre ja durchaus möglich.
Aber da habe ich als Firma doch kein Interesse, da teilzunehmen.
Wieso, wenn meine Ressourcen besser ausgelastet werden? Ein Fitnessstuhl hat permanent das Problem, dass die halt extrem bursty sind. Deswegen machen wir dieses Differential Pricing. Also die Ressourcen besser auslasten, ist für jedes Unternehmen durchaus von Interesse. Und deswegen könnte das tatsächlich funktionieren, macht aber niemand, wird niemand tun, weil klar ist, dass Google und Facebook könnten das innerhalb von ein paar Wochen einfach nachmachen, platt machen und dann wäre der Service tot, weil dann kriegst du es for free halt irgendwie in dem existierenden Service. Und das ist halt dieses Business-Modell, was halt Google und Facebook treiben, dieses Dealing the Oxygen, also dem anderen halt nicht genug Luft zum Atmen lassen. Und das führt halt dazu, dass solche Modelle, die halt irgendwie, wo man sagen könnte, okay, die sind jetzt nicht nur völlige Bullshit-Disruption, sondern halt auch möglicherweise sinnvoll, finden halt nicht mehr statt. Und dasselbe passiert mittlerweile auch im Machine-Learning-Bereich, dass also tatsächlich die Leute, die halt irgendwie innovative und geile Ideen haben, finden keine Leute mehr. Weil die Gehälter, die Google und Facebook sozusagen zahlen können und Apple sind halt...
Das war sogar ein Argument bei einem Vortrag, den ich dieses Jahr gehalten hab.
Die sind halt so hoch, dass die Kalkulation für...
Kannst du nicht konkurrieren....
machst du halt Start-up-Lotto und hoffst, dass deine Firma wahrscheinlich 1 zu 10 wird, selbst wenn du gut bist. Versus irgendwie, du nimmst halt die Hubble-Million jetzt gleich mit, ist ja ein No-Brain für die Allermeisten. Weil Start-up kannst du ja immer noch machen, wenn die Lage besser geworden ist. Deswegen gibt es halt gerade so einen Innovation-Slowdown. Ziemlich interessant eigentlich. Ohne Konzentration auf die Großen halt.
Ja, aber das ist ja eigentlich, ist das nicht schon immer so gewesen, dass sich das bei den Großen konzentriert? Ich meine, dass irgendwie IBM sofort alles nachbaut und botzen nennt.
Die waren aber nie glücklich.
Nein, naja, aber sind ja Google und so jetzt auch nicht.
Doch.
Na ja.
Erfolgreich sind die schon.
Ja, erfolgreich, aber sind nicht irgendwie sind nicht die Speerspitze der Innovation der Welt.
Also bei KRI ist, wenn man sich anguckt, wo die so richtig geilen Papers herkommen, kommen, also kann man sagen, zu 80 Prozent sind das halt irgendwie kein akademischen Papers mehr, sondern kommen aus den großen Firmen. Also wirklich den großen Firmen. So und die Chinesen halt immer ganz vorne mit dabei, weil die halt dieselben Rahmenbedingungen haben. Viele Daten, große Computer. Und das ist halt schon so ein...
Und günstigen Strom, das wollten wir eigentlich bei Bitcoin erzählen. Erzähl doch mal die Anekdote von, warum der Strom, warum es in meinen Augen überhaupt lohnt.
Also eine der schönen Legenden, um den Bitcoin in China ist ja, dass der Strom da ersetzt nicht unbedingt nur aus fiesen Kohlekraftwerken kommt, die halt für billig irgendwie den Planeten verbrennen, sondern dass die halt auch so Teler haben mit irgendwie Wasserkraftwerken, die über Kapazität gebaut wurden, also wo halt mehr Strom anfällt als lokal verbraucht werden kann. Und dass die Bitcoin-Miner halt in diese Teler direkt neben die Wasserkraftwerke halt ihre Hallen gebaut haben und dann da halt den Überkapazitätsstrom aus den Wasserkraftwerken, die die ja nicht wegkriegen, weil es da keine großen Leitungen gibt, halt einfach in Bitcoin verbrennen. Und also eine mögliche Differenzierung wäre tatsächlich, dass es dann demnächst einen irgendeinen Öko-Coin gibt, der sagt, wir meinen nur mit Wasserkraft.
Da haben aber die Libertären was dagegen, oder?
Da hätten die Libertären sicherlich was dagegen, ja.
Gut, aber das wäre natürlich auch für Machine Learning denkbar, dass China da aus dieser geografischen Stromüberkapazität einfach sich da eine Vormachtstellung holt, weil sie sozusagen kostenlos...
Naja, der Strom ist glaube ich weniger ein Problem, als die Hardware-Inestition. Also wenn du dir anguckst, sowieso das Verhältnis zwischen Compute Power, die du ins Learning steckst, und Compute Power bei der Ausführung, ist es halt irgendwie in mehrere Größenordnungen. Das ist halt um mehrere Größenordnungen mehr Compute Power, die du halt beim Learning brauchst.
Das hat die Chinesen nicht aufgehalten. Als sie den fetten ultramonster-mega-supercomputer gebaut haben.
Na ja, warum sie den gebaut haben, war eigentlich sehr interessant. Den haben sie gebaut, weil die Amis nicht blickig genug waren. Die Amis sind ja zu Intel gegangen und haben gesagt, wir würden gerne einen fetten ultramega-supercomputer bauen und hätten dafür gerne ein paar Zillionen CPOs und hier ist unser Geld. Und dann haben die Amis gesagt, nee, dann haben die Chinesen ja den dicksten supercomputer, Intel, du darfst nicht. Und Intel hat gesagt, naja, are you sure?
Und dann haben wir diesen Investor in Dubai verkauft.
Nee, nee. Und dann haben die Chinesen gesagt, dann machen wir halt unseren eigenen. Und jetzt, die haben ihre eigenen CPOs da reingebaut. Also die haben halt irgendwie nicht gesagt, wir warten drauf, bis Intel oder AMD sich jetzt mal um diese irgendwie Beukotten war, da halt rumgewuselt haben, haben wir einfach reinge CPOs gebaut.
Ja, noch mal dieser MIPS-Klon. So ein Loon Song oder so. Naja, aber der Punkt ist, die Chinesen könnten es. Das ist so eins der wenigen Länder, die das einfach mal machen könnten. So eigene Machine Learning, CPOs bauen und dann einfach die Pläne heben.
Also das ist halt nun, also auch die, also das ist ja gerade der große Trend, dass also zumindest im Westen die Big Five bauen sich hier spezialisierte Hardware dafür. Und bei den Chinesen ist es halt auch so, also dass die halt dann einfach, einiges davon ist ja sogar Open Source. Also Facebook hat ja tatsächlich seine Designs für die, für die Hardware sogar Open Source. Und ich glaube Baidu oder jedenfalls einer von den Chinesen hat es irgendwie, hat die dann auch irgendwie herzig geiler akzeptiert und baute halt ihre eigene Werte davon.
Also ich kann mir ehrlich gesagt nicht vorstellen, dass das viel effizienter wird als Grafikkarten, weil das genau die Kernanwendung ist. Also gerade der Trend im Moment geht hin, dass die Grafikkarten nicht mehr nur 32 und 64-Bit-Arythmetik machen, so Floating Point, sondern so 16, 16-Bit und vielleicht 8-Bit. Und das ist genau, wird verkauft als irgendwie Tensor, irgendwas blubber Machine Learning. Aber das ist sowas von genau, was du brauchst für sowohl Machine Learning als auch für so Bildbearbeitung, wofür die gedacht sind. Insofern, also das kann ja, dass die jetzt irgendwie kurzfristig einen Edge haben, kann ja sein. Aber langfristig kann man mit denen, glaube ich, nicht konkurrieren.
Na, es gibt halt schon so spezialisierte Hardware, die unter anderem zum Beispiel von IBM entwickelt wird.
Was genau macht die denn besser als so eine Grafikkarte?
Das habe ich mir im Detail noch nicht angeguckt. Also das wäre halt, da können wir mal einen flippenden Sinn geben, an jemand, der sich da auskennt. Ich weiß es einfach nicht. Ich habe nur die Papers mir kurz angeguckt und gesehen, dass sie halt bei bestimmten Machine-Learning-Anwendungen gegenüber Grafikkarten Faktor 100 gebracht haben. Und das wäre halt, also nicht bei generisch allen, aber zumindest bei bestimmten Varianten davon. Und das wäre halt schon beim Training.
Das ist natürlich schon substanziell.
Genau.
Und auf der anderen Seite, wie viel musst du wirklich trainieren? Ist es nicht so, dass man dafür heutzutage einfach die Cloud mietet? Du brauchst es ja nicht für lange, diese Infrastruktur. Das ist doch völlig bescheuert, wenn du dir da irgendwie heilenweise...
Bei dem jetzigen System von Machine Learning, wo du halt irgendwie eine Learning-Phase hast und dann brennst du das Netz halt quasi fest. Und die Frage wird halt, ob zum Beispiel halt irgendwie mit so was wie Recurrent Machine Learning und irgendwie den Systemen, die dann halt eine Auswahl treffen, was jetzt irgendwie das notwendige Learning-System ist, ob man damit nicht halt eher so tase mal so was wie Alltagsbegleitendes lernen macht.
Also das tatsächlich, das willst du doch nicht wirklich auch nur ernsthaft darüber nachdenken.
Das ist das, was die Leute tun werden.
Stell dir mal vor, ich weiß ja, ich muss an diese ganzen schlechten Star Trek, irgendwie Sci-Fi Geschichten denken, wo sie den den Androiden flaschen und der seine dazu gelernten Emotionen verliert. Das haben wir doch alles zigfach in Sci-Fi durch irgendwie iteriert.
Kann nur so.
Was passiert, wenn nur irgendwie deine künstliche Intelligenz neu reset ist? Das ist doch die Dystopie, das ist doch die eins der Standard-Tropes seit vielen Jahren.
Also es gibt da tatsächlich irgendwie jetzt so diesen durchaus einen Zweig in diesem ganzen Wie geht es denn weiter mit dem Machine Learning, die halt sagen so Machine Learning supervised learning. Das heißt also, dass es halt irgendwie kein unsupervised learning ist, sondern dass man halt irgendwie quasi sich einen Machine Learning Meta-Controller baut, der halt das learning von den darunter liegende Systemen beobachtet und dann halt die dann halt irgendwie in den Bahnen hält.
Ich hab irgendwie den Eindruck, ich bin der Letzte, der gerne irgendwie in der Lage sein möchte, Aussagen über sein System zu treffen.
Oh, das möchten wir alle gerne, aber wir sind sehr weit weg davon.
Ja, warum? Das ist doch eine Sache, die musst du halt herbeiführen und dann ist es so.
Also wir haben auf dem Kongress, glaube ich, mindestens einen Talk über Leute, die selber ihre Chips bauen. Und ich glaube, da werden wir hinkommen.
Gut, da kommen wir noch, da sind wir gerade näher als seit Langem, weil es jetzt diese Risk-Five-Geschichte gibt. Also seit Langem sehe ich mal wieder Hoffnungen, aber das muss man dann halt tun. Und stattdessen haben wir jetzt alle irgendwelche Management Engine Scheiße in unseren CPUs drin. Das ist so ein Weg, der offensichtlich Scheiße ist, das verschlägt mir die Sprache, warum wir überhaupt hingegangen sind. So was, was, naja. Also ich hab nicht mal irgendwie ein mentales Modell was erklären kann. Irgendwie hat die NSA einfach Intel mit vorgehaltener Schrottflinte oder was? Ich versteh's nicht. Warum sind wir, wo wir gerade sind? Es kann ich nicht...
Ich würde sagen, ein Zusammentreffen von Kapitalismus und Geheimdienst unterwanderte Absolute Demokratie könnte...
Na und warum macht AMD das dann auch?
Vielleicht haben sie gute Gründe. Ich weiß nicht, wie ihr größter Kunde aus Cray hat, nur existiert, weil die NSA ihre Maschinen gekauft hat.
Da hat die NSA das nicht immer dementiert.
Klar.
Nein, nein, das ist ein Großinvestor, der nicht namentlich genannt wird. Ach, ich weiß nicht, das ist doch alles. Na gut, aber wir haben hier lauter dystopische Visionen jedenfalls. Wir haben hier noch irgendwie, wenn man mal guckt, wo die KI überall hin tentakelt gerade. Also Aktienhandel mit KI wird sogar schon gemacht. So Portfolio-Management.
Das bietet sich ja auch eigentlich an.
Autofahren. Aber Autofahren ist, glaube ich, mit dem Schritt sind sie zu schnell gegangen. Da haben die Leute noch zu viel Angst vor. Das ist die Nummer eins Sorge, die die Leute mit KI haben. Selbstfahrende Autos. Das ist das erste, was der Mann auf der Straße irgendwie greifen kann als Problem bei KI.
Die gewöhnen jetzt die Leute einfach dran. Deswegen haben sie so früh angefangen.
Ja, das kann natürlich sein. Also es scheint auch zu funktionieren.
Wurde einfach eine Weile dauern, bis es halt wirklich großflächig in der Praxis ist.
Eine Generation heißt es immer so schön, ne? Die gute Ideen setzen sich ja nicht durch, weil sie irgendwie überzeugen, sondern weil die aussterben, die nicht an sie glauben. Scheiße.
Tja, und dann ist die Frage, was mit deinem Job passiert, wenn jemand irgendwie anfängt, eine ordentliche Machine Learning System mit das Blöd zu verheiraten?
Ach, da mach ich mir wenig so.
Meinst du?
Ja, also ich mein, es ist... Bug finden ist ihm nicht... Ja, also ich find auch interessanter die Frage, wie wir Systeme bauen können, damit die nicht anfällig sind. Und das kann ich auch und erst recht machen, wenn ich einen guten Gegenspieler hab, der irgendwie Bugs findet. Also ich finde viel wichtiger, als irgendwie einzelne Bugs zu finden und zu fixen, weil dann bist du genau da, wo du vorher auch warst. Ja, finde ich. Wie kannst du die Architektur deiner Software so bauen, dass gewisse Bug-Klassen einfach weg sind? Das ist doch die Herausforderung. Wie, welche Software-Entwicklungsmethoden müssen wir anwenden, damit wir am Ende noch eine Aussage treffen können über das System? Ja, im Moment ist es ist doch unser Umgang mit Software ist so, ich will mal sagen, phenomenologisch. Wir gucken von außen drauf und sagen, wenn wir hier drücken, passiert das.
Wie ein Haustier.
Ja, aber es ist doch scheiße. Ich meine gut, auf der anderen Seite ist dann nachvollziehbar, warum die Leute kein Problem haben, damit KI rein zu holen.
Weil für die sieht es eh schon so aus.
Ja, aber das ist doch selbst zugefügte Wunde, dass es so aussieht im Moment. Das ist völlig unnötig. Das liegt einfach daran, dass wir pfuschen.
Naja, ich meine, ein hinreichend komplexes Thema sieht halt einfach aus wie Magie. Ja, ist halt so.
Ja, muss aber nicht. Also von außen vielleicht. Aber der Punkt ist, wenn man im Moment, im Moment haben wir so fraktale Software. Je näher du rangehst, desto schlimmere Komplexitätsuntiefen tun sich auf. Und das ist komplett selbstverschuldet. Da gibt es keinen Grund für.
Naja, also ich meine, so dieser Trend irgendwie, dass man halt heutzutage keine Software mehr bauen kann, ohne 45 Hipster-Libraries zu inheriten und dann halt...
Fraktale Software muss ich mir, glaube ich, mal müssen wir uns mal merken als Begriff.
Wir wollten doch sowieso ein neues Institut, nicht wahr?
Genau, das von Leitner Institut für fraktale Software-Forschung.
Fraktale Software-Komplexität, ja das stimmt.
Das ist doch alles. Ja, aber guck mal, weißt du, das nimmt mich wirklich mit, dass im Grunde alle dasselbe Problem sehen, aber keiner versucht es zu lösen. Alle so, ach, ey, wenn wir schon so weit im Abgrund sind, dann können wir auch noch schnell die Maschine wieder in den Grain holen.
Also ich hatte ja neulich irgendwie so dieses lustige Erlebnis, dass ich irgendwie versucht habe, mal zu gucken, was ist die maximale Anzahl Zeilencode, die ich verwenden kann, um ein Problem zu lösen.
Oh nein, das ist glaube ich unbegrenzt.
Und also mein Problem war halt, ich wollte eine Temperatur und Luftwächtigkeit messen.
Das geht auch ganz ohne Code.
Naja, ich wollte es auch aufzeichnen. Tatsächlich ist der einfachste Weg, dass man am einfachsten zum Ziel kommt.
Ich glaube, ich will das gar nicht.
Besteht darin tatsächlich irgendwie eine bisschen Aluino-Software, wo dann schon noch eine Menge Libraries dazukommen, die halt mit diesem Sensor reden und die mit dem HTTP reden. Dann den Kram in eine Key-Value-Store-Database zu tun.
Verteilt mit Konsensus?
Ja, muss man nicht haben, habe ich mir gespart.
Ja wie, aber HTTP musst du haben?
Die dann halt in die Datemann schreibt, naja, muss halt. Und dann wollte ich natürlich noch schöne Grafen darauf haben und ein bisschen Auswertung machen. Und dann habe ich mir dann die entsprechenden Hipster-Systeme dazu geklickt.
Hast du den wenigstens SSL ausgewollt?
Nein, das ist nur noch ein Expo, aber das ist noch nicht ausgerollt. Jedenfalls, am Ende stellt er sich halt heraus, dass der einfachste Weg, also diese sozusagen, diesen Key-Value-Store mit irgendwie dem Grafenmalen und so weiter Dings da dazu zu kriegen, ist mir einfach von der Firma, die das MongoDB-Installation anbietet, nein, das fertige Docker-Image zu holen, was ist denn alles enthält, was ich brauche, weil tatsächlich war es halt wirklich sehr viel einfacher. Also Docker ist halt sozusagen so eine Komplexitätsreduktion durch...
Nee, überhaupt nicht.
Ist schon, nein, für den User.
Ist eine Bedienung, ja.
Weil du musst halt nichts mehr tun. Du nimmst ja ein fertiges Docker-Image und du musst nicht verstehen, was du tust.
Dafür ist es dann auch scheiße.
Und du musst halt nur noch irgendwelche Webforms halt ein paar Zahlen ergeben, um den richtigen Port zu konfigurieren und dir dein Accesspunkt zu generieren.
Klar taugt das nix, aber dafür ist es auch richtig schlecht.
Und sehr bunt. Genau. Also ich hab noch nicht gezielt, aber es dürfen ein paar Millionen Zeilen kurz sein, die dann irgendwie dafür, dass ich irgendwie einen Grafen auf einer...
Folie-Hipster-Compliment.
Genau. Und ich glaube, das ist tatsächlich so dieser Trend, den wir jetzt halt überall haben, dass du halt... Die meisten Webseiten funktionieren halt nicht, wenn Google nicht funktioniert, weil sie halt Google-Funk-Appys nachladen und ein bisschen anderen Kram von Google. Und also deswegen...
Ja, vor allem ajax.google.com ist immer so das Ding, was man erlauben muss.
Und Fonts.
Ja, Fonts geht auch ohne. Das ist gut genug, die Fonts-Skripte, die dir reinladen. Das ist auch ohne Render. Dabei sieht dann halt nicht so... sieht halt anders aus. Aber wenn du Ajax nicht erlaubst oder AMP, dann kannst du inzwischen kaum noch Nachrichten klicken, weil die Leute reichen alle Google-AMP-Links rum und das ist geht gar nicht.
Ich glaube dieser Trend halt einfach, dass die Bequemlichkeit ein System zu bauen und das Outsourcen von Verantwortung an diese Hipster-Libraries und Services, dass das der Treiber dabei ist. Auf jeden Fall. Dass du also die Verantwortung für schwierige Probleme nicht mehr selber übernimmst, sondern sie halt an irgendjemand outsourcest, der dieses Problem schon mal gelöst hat.
Du übernimmst sie ja doch, aber du redest ja ein, du hättest sie nicht übernommen. Weil die Leute dann alle sagen können, und das ist völlig einmalig, nur bei Software funktioniert das. Ja, wieso? Das hab ich doch von da genommen. Stell dir mal vor, VW sagt dir, ja, die Komponente haben wir von Bosch gekauft.
Da machen sie ja.
Ja, nee, nee, nee. Nein, nein, also sagen sie natürlich, aber Bosch sagt ja, wieso? Wir haben hier ordentliche Verträge und da steht drin, geliefert wie bestellt. Ja, und bei Software sagst du so, ich strecke meine Hände, gen Himmel und weise alle schuld von mir und alle sagen, ja, dann ist es halt so. Ja, also das geht mal gar nicht.
Also ich glaube jedenfalls, dass diese Verantwortungsdiffusion damit zu tun hat, dass...
Ja, und dies ist Absicht auf beiden Seiten. Sowohl, so das finde ich das Krasse daran. Beide Seiten haben ein Interesse daran, das voranzutreiben, weil unterm Strich dann überhaupt niemand mehr Verantwortung hat. Ja, wir haben so ein, das war ja auch lange Zeit meine Arbeitsthese, warum bei BER nicht einfach irgendwie Licht ausgemacht wird, sondern warum da jetzt noch irgendwelche Firmen irgendwas machen, damit am Ende das Geflecht so groß geworden ist an den externen Dienstleistern, dass keiner mehr irgendwie sagen kann, wer jetzt woran schuld ist und dann ist halt irgendwie überhaupt. Und das fühlen wir bei Software eben auch herbei und zwar absichtlich, glaube ich, sehenden Auges. Weil einfach alle Seiten Interesse daran haben, die Komplexität so zu erhöhen, dass keiner mehr tatsächlich schuld ist.
Wobei die meisten Leute, glaube ich, nicht in der Form sind nicht von Schuld, sondern von Bequemlichkeit denken auf der Programmiererseite und weil ich meine, letzten Endes sind halt ganz viele Softwareprojekte da draußen funktionieren halt genauso, ja? Also Leute, die sich eine Lösung von Stack-Exchange zusammencopy-pasten und der 25 URLs von irgendwelchen externen Hipster-Services drinne stehen, dann auch mal irgendwie 20 Zeilen Glucode.
Mehr Bugs als Codezeilen.
Ja und so und dann halt einfach davon abhängig sind, dass irgendwie keiner von diesen 25 externen zugelinkten Services und irgendwie what not irgendwie hinreichend viele Probleme hat. Und wenn doch einer ein Problem hat oder es Inkompatibilitäten gibt, dann musst du halt diese Probleme fixen. Und da entwickeln die Leute dann auch so eine Erfahrung drin. Na also die entwickeln Erfahrung darin, diese Probleme, also diese Klasse Probleme zu finden und rauszufinden, welche Version von welcher Komponente jetzt zufällig mit der wieder zusammen funktioniert.
Ja und alle Seiten befördern das, indem sie irgendwelche automatisierten Bug-Tracker betreiben auch noch, ja. Sodass du immer jemanden hast. Also es gibt ja keins von diesen Frameworks ohne ein System, wo du eine Meldung hinterlassen kannst, dass irgendwas nicht geht. Sodass ich, wenn ich das jetzt einsetze und es geht nicht, kann ich sagen, ja, ich habe alles getan. Ja, ich bin hingegangen, habe einen Bug gefilet. Jetzt müssen wir warten. Nur so. Aber das ist ja völlig freiwillig, dass ich das aus der Hand gegeben habe, dass ich noch was fixen kann.
Ich überlege gerade, ob die Blockchain dieses Problem vielleicht löst.
Verdammt.
Einige von diesen neumodischen Coins, z.B. Jota, die da gerade ein bisschen Probleme haben, versuchen ja genau dieses zu lösen, dass sie sagen, der Hipster-Service, den du benutzen willst, der kostet dann ein paar hundertstel Cent pro Nutzungseinheit, der über eine Blockchain-Währung abgerechnet wird. Vielleicht, wenn dieses Zeug dann Geld kostet, dann entsteht auch wieder so etwas wie Verantwortung. Zum einen muss man Geld ausgeben und zum anderen bekommen die Leute auch Geld, die diese diese Dienste betreiben und müssen nicht halt irgendwie nur von ihrer Startup-Kohle und der Hoffnung auf irgendwelche Beratungsstils leben.
Das klingt genauso wie dieses Schönreden vor allen Start-up-Blasen und vor Atomenergie.
Ich stelle nur eine wilde Theorie auf hier. Ich habe jetzt nicht gesagt, dass es so sein wird. Du wolltest nur mal die Theorie posten.
Die unsichtbare Hand des Marktes wird dafür sorgen.
Bevor ein Leser uns damit kommt, wollte ich es zumindest mal erwähnt haben. Ich glaube, wir nehmen auch Jotacoin.
Okay, da sorgst du aber für die sofortige Konvertierung in irgendwas, was keine offensichtlichen...
Nein, das werde ich natürlich nicht tun, weil das würde nämlich tatsächlich das Experiment beschädigen.
Das Experiment ist dir wichtiger, als dass du es am Ende ausgeben kannst.
Das Experiment ist natürlich irgendwie, dass es in zwölf Monaten noch da ist. Wenn inzwischen durch der Coin leider Bast gegangen ist, naja, dann war es wohl ein scheiß Coin. Ist doch ganz einfach.
Gut, aber das könntest du ja auch machen. Du könntest ja virtuell machen. Du ziehst die Kohle raus und guckst dann.
Ja, mal gucken.
Aber du spekulierst halt insgeheim doch darauf, dass die zehn, die du gewählt hast, zumindest im Durchschnitt deutlich nach umgehen wird. Wenn du nämlich ein Zocker bist.
Wir werden die Regeln zwischendurch noch...
Zocker, du... Ja klar, die Regeln werden der Realität angepackt.
Die werden noch ein bisschen fach. Also nur zur Optimierung des Unterhaltungsfaktors natürlich. Ist doch klar. Na gut, da haben wir uns, glaube ich, so ein bisschen durch. Dann danken wir fürs Zuhören. Wie gesagt, wenn ihr Lust habt, uns eure überzähligen Coins, egal welcher Provinienz, für dieses Experiment anzuvertrauen, dann werdet ihr da irgendwie Wallet-Adressen auf der Webseite finden. Ansonsten gibt es immer noch den Patreon-Button, und wir überlegen uns auch noch, wie es weitergeht. Wie viel für schon, sagt ihr, wir wollen versuchen, nächstes Jahr tatsächlich mal ein paar mehr Sendungen zu machen, auch mit externen Gästen, um halt irgendwie das Problem des mangelnden inhaltlichen Diskurses mal wieder so ein bisschen auszugleichen.
Ja, und wir wollen auch, dass hier ein bisschen mehr Stil kommt.
Stil, ja, wir und Stil.
Naja, also zumindest, gut, vielleicht ist Stil der falsche Begriff, sagen wir mal Niveau.
Niveau, ah ja, okay.
Ja, ist mir wichtig, nicht nur zu reden, sondern auch, dass du am Ende zurückblickst und sagst, das war ein schönes Gespräch.
Das stimmt, ja. Also ich meine, die Qualität eines intellektuellen Arguments ist halt schon immer doch befriedigender als alles andere. Naja, das stimmt schon. Na gut, in diesem Sinne, vielen Dank fürs Zuhören.
Frohes Fest. Ich hoffe, wir können es noch releasen vor Weihnachten.
Ich denke, ja, wir werden es einfach releasen.
Naja, im Moment ist hier im Grunde Land unter bei allen Freiwilligen wegen Kongress.
Wir werden es wahrscheinlich einfach nur irgendwie durch...
Wir schaffen es schon....
einfach leveln und irgendwie releasen. Und da müsst ihr uns verzeihen dafür, dass da noch ein paar Bartschaber und Schnaufer zwischendurch sind. Das ist dann halt so.
Nächstes Mal sehen wir uns wieder.
Genau. Nächstes Mal sehen wir uns wieder. In diesem Sinne ein frohes Fest und schönes Kongress.